it was really shocking that nobody else
was doing anything creative with sex
work like for me it was it was like
breathing like you're just doing sex and
you're bored I'm like what do you do I
don't know let's try something funny
like it's just the natural progression
and it felt to me like there was almost
no competition like I would just be
really creative and like immediately
lose the top not safe for post on Reddit
I'm like well I didn't even try that
hard
the following is a conversation with
Ayla a sex researcher who does some of
the largest human sexuality survey
studies in the world on everything from
fetishes to relationships she is
fearless in pursuing her Curiosity on
these Topics by asking challenging and
fascinating questions and looking for
answers in a rigorous data-driven way
and writing about it on her blog
knowinglust.com
she's also a sex worker including only
fans and escorting and is an
exceptionally prolific creator of
thought-provoking Twitter polls
Ayla and I disagree on a bunch of things
but that just made this conversation
even more interesting
I like interesting people in the full
range of the meaning that the word
interesting implies
I'm currently reading on the road by
Jack Kerouac
and uh would be remiss if I didn't
mention one of my favorite quotes from
that book that feels relevant here
the only people for me are the Mad ones
the ones who are mad to Live Matt to
talk mad to be saved desirous of
everything at the same time the ones who
never yawn or say a commonplace thing
but burn burn burn
like fabulous yellow Roman candles
exploding like spiders across the Stars
in the middle you see the blue Center
Light Pop and everybody goes
this is the Lex Friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's Ayla
I feel like this conversation can go
anywhere is that exciting or terrifying
to you I think it's more exciting the
uncertainty exciting too
yes
in conversations in general or just this
one I think conversations in general
like is anybody that got a certainty is
really exciting maybe if the certainty
is something new I mean novelty always
comes with uncertainty right almost
always I started trying to think of a
counter example
immediately yeah you're uncomfortable
with generalizations of that kind like
always is always a really bold for a
tears but if it's truly novel that means
you don't really understand it's outside
your distribution so therefore it's
going to have a bunch of uncertainty but
you don't think of it as uncertainty you
think about his
something new
but it actually also attracts you
because there's a lot of uncertainty
surround it probably like what is this
new thing yeah like annihilating the
mystery like that drive what about the
danger of it
it's like part I was just thinking of on
the drive over because I kind of like a
little nervous about doing this podcast
and then I was like feeling into the
unpleasantness of it like the like the
fear of what if something goes terribly
wrong and then I was also feeling into
like how much that feels like part of
why it's exciting like
if I knew that it was going to go great
I don't know did you actually imagine
all the possible ways you can it can go
wrong not like all of them but I was
like what if I say something really dumb
or like you ask me a question and I
answer it in a way that makes me sound
like a lot less capable than I am I'm
like really afraid of being perceived as
stupid or something I was also thinking
about this on the way over like I'm kind
of risk-averse in some ways like I don't
driving fat like driving fast in cars
because I was driving very carefully
here because the roads are bad yeah and
then I think I'm very like pro-risk in
other ways like being really exposed to
like a wide variety of people who might
hate you and I think like from the
outside that might look fine but I think
the monkey brain is really sensitive to
lots of people yelling at you
for whatever problems that you seem to
have so that's the big risk you're
taking is putting yourself out there as
an intellectual like through your
writing and then a lot of people yelling
at you is that is that the worst
embarrassment it's pretty bad yeah I
think I think the worst embarrassment is
if I put something out there that I
failed to like be properly skeptical of
in myself
and then people are like oh we just
caught this thing that you didn't catch
I think that's the biggest Terror yeah
from looking at your reading and
listening to your interviews
you seem to be very defensive and
worried about being good scientists yeah
definitely well you're like methodology
yes and funny enough you get attacked on
that methodology even though
you know I've I'm a fan of psychology of
like the academic psychology and it's
it's kind of disappointing often how
non-rigorous their work is how small the
sample size and so on and how big and
ambitious over ambitious the the
proclamations about results is
especially with the news reports on it
now you're both the researcher the
scientist And the reporter right so like
that's what you have with the blog your
sample size is often gigantic
the methodology is right there the data
is right there you provide the data and
then you're like
raw and honest with your interpretation
of the day like there's of honesty
authenticity to it
so I don't it's actually really
refreshing I don't know why people
criticize it I think this is what peop
this is what psychologists are probably
terrified about being transparent and
transparent in that way is because
they'll get attacked for their
methodology so they want to cloak it in
a um
in a sort of layer of authority like I'm
from this institution it was peer
reviewed this kind of all these layers
and I'm also not going to share the data
with you and I'm also going to pretend
like most psychology studies are not
replicable I'm just going to pretend
there's authority to it I think it works
a lot of people like from the outside
you're like ah the scientists with the
white lab coats with credentials those
are the people who are like doing
science and like doing science is you
know you have like fancy terms that
other people are don't really understand
and to be fair like I I have a lot to
learn I'm still like I'm self-teaching
I'm like learning through people
learning as I go I'm definitely not
super knowledgeable about this stuff
um but a lot of what those people are
doing in science is not that hard
um and a lot of people like don't try to
learn it because it seems so like
elevated and this is one thing that
really bothers me I think like everybody
can do science like if you just have
this aspect of curiosity and like you
just really want to figure something out
you can go and start you know asking
people questions doing surveys like
writing down the answers and the you go
learn how to look at that data in a way
that gives you more information about
the world like it's very simple and
straightforward if you just approach it
humbly and earnestly and you're like
please let's look let's figure this out
together but people like are think
self-crippled in this because uh they
view this as like
relegated to the domain of the experts
and you know the fancy scientists and I
think that makes me feel really sad
you're almost attracted to the questions
you're not supposed to ask oh yeah also
yes we might contribute to the
controversy not exclusively probably I
don't know you're just not limited by
like part of your curiosity is asking
questions that seem common sense like
what is some of the most controversial
questions are like around sex it's like
everybody thinks and talks and does sex
I mean it's it's the driver of human
civilization and yet there's so little
like a rigorous discussion about the
like the philosophical and the
scientific questions around it it's like
it gets really weird
to be able to discuss them it becomes
tricky to discuss them yeah supercharged
super because everybody has a really
strong opinion like whether or not you
know pornography is damaging to society
or like how sex corresponds to gender or
like what kind of sexuality is
acceptable like do can you have sexual
preferences that in them in themselves
are immoral uh people get very angry
about it well the sad part
is they're not just opinionated but most
of us our relationship with sex is a
I think I guess I want to say not
rigorous
I think it's very difficult to be
rigorous about sex like and I I would
consider uh sexual urges to be kind of
elusive to introspection in a way that's
a little bit disproportionate to a lot
of other things like you could like you
know introspect about you know how I
want other people to like me and
um how where my insecurities lie but sex
is one of those black box things a
really common thing is for people to if
you have a fetish you sort of check back
in your childhood to see an event that
corresponds to that fetish and then you
like develop a narrative like ah this
event in my childhood must have caused
this fetish and so I think this causes
people to be biased towards like a like
a concrete coherent causative way that
events happen or there's that sexual
fetishes happen
um this is just like one example of like
why I think it's really hard to be
rigorous with introspection because we
can't avoid you just want to tend
towards making like coherent narratives
which I think is not always the correct
way to explain it the narratives that
are connected to Childhood and soil and
so on yeah they origin is yeah you've uh
I mean we'll talk about fetishes because
you have a lot of really interesting
writing on that just actually zooming
out I should mention you tweeted I wrote
this down you tweeted I do not
understand how to have normal
conversations with people in person
if I'm not on drugs
so I guess
so let's both agree to not have a normal
conversation I guess assuming you're not
on drugs now or if you are Duke you
don't have to talk I feel like a very
small amount of fun a bit okay which is
a nootropic
I don't know if that counts instead of
drug well I guess I'm on caffeine yeah
so we're both
drugged up good enough to have a normal
conversation
uh we don't have to
what is normal anyway uh what do you
think is the primary driver of human
civilization is it the desire for sex
love power or immortality like avoiding
uh the fear of death constructing
illusions that make us forget about our
Terror over mortality so sex love power
death is this a Twitter poll it's a poor
option this is reality not everything it
Maps perfectly into a Twitter poll but
in this case because there's four
options and it is a small number of
characters it does but I'd like to think
I'm more interested you know what
I think your Twitter polls are
fundamentally interesting there's
something about the the brevity of a
poll limiting to a set of choices and
having an existential crisis and
searching for the answer
that's beautiful that combination well
this one's a big one like what do you
think is behind it do you believe that
there is one primary driver like do you
think that it can be understood in the
terms of primary drivers
yeah I think well maybe it's an
engineering perspective like trying to
reverse engineer the brain I don't think
we're equipped or understanding enough
about the mind to get there yeah like
what's the primary driver of a tree
yeah well then it gets the question of
what is life what is a living organism
to self-replicate probably that's a very
clean simplification but
I think life
is more interesting that
than just self-replication yeah but it
sounds like you there's a curiosity in
you that you're trying to like poke at
and I don't understand exactly what that
curiosity is so if I if I had to
dedicate a thousand years to understand
one of these topics which one would be
the most fruitful I guess is the
indirect thing I'm asking
no well fun after to me everything is
fun but I feel like yeah I mean I'm with
David Foster Wallace the key to life is
uh to make sure that everything is
unborrowable or to be unborrowable or
ever nothing is boring everything is fun
every like everything I'll could just
literally sit I honestly because I don't
think I don't know where you got that
glass but that glass exists and I forgot
it exists it was really fun to me to
know that now I was there but I felt
like really things
like if you're in like a deep agony
yeah that's fun okay that's fun because
it's like I mean yeah heartbreak is like
knowing that I'm capable of that it it
like from
uh you know we're all living in the
gutter but some of us are looking up at
the stars so when you're in that gutter
for some reason the stars look brighter
right like so like whenever you're going
through a difficult time
or whenever you see maybe other people
being shitty to each other it makes you
like really appreciate when they're not
the contrast makes life kind of amazing
I'm reading a bunch of books one of them
is Brave New World where they remove
Contra you know where they remove the
ups and downs of life
um partially through drugs but over over
sexualization all that kind of stuff and
I feel like you need
that Contra you need the ups and downs
of life
uh the dark you know you need the dark
to have happiness have like a deeply
intense feeling of affection towards
another thing or a human being yeah yeah
so everything's fun but fun is also a
weird word to Define because fun I think
for a lot of people in
like that's why I talk about love a lot
I I think I think love is a better word
than fun
because fun is like light-hearted
love is more intense
like I love that class and the water
that's in it because it's freaking
awesome like somebody made that glass
right like they and like not have many
mistakes and like there's a and the way
Ben's light in interesting ways and the
way water Blends light in interesting
ways like I can see part of your R into
that water
that's freaking amazing everything is
amazing
I'm with the Lego movie anyway
um if but if like from a scientific
perspective if I were to investigate sex
I don't know why I put love in there
let's just narrowed down the Twitter
poll let's focus on the basics here sex
power or death immortality
if I were to try to
like from a neuroscience neobiology
perspective or reverse engineer if
they're building AI systems that focus
on these kinds of Dynamics exploring the
gang theoretic aspects of it uh
exploring
the sort of cognitive modeling aspects
of it which one would get me to a deeper
understanding of The Human Condition
that's the question sex
okay Nietzsche is the will to power
uh Freud and and the bunch is all about
sex
and then
um death
uh live just uh live Burley
brilliant previous guest on this podcast
she just released a video where on her
bedside was the book denial of death
uh by owners Becker which of course you
would have on her bedside but that the
his whole work is that everything is
motivated by our trying to escape the
the cold harsh reality that we're going
to die and we're terrified of it one of
the gifts and burdens
for human beings is that we are
cognizant of our own death
and that terrifies us that's the theory
and because of that we do everything we
can we build we build Empires to escape
the fact that we're mortal wouldn't this
change quite a bit for religious people
then who don't believe that they're
going to die well they created religion
the idea there to create myths religions
you can create religions of all kinds
like yeah but if this is like one of the
defining things that
Define civilization then we should
expect to see like massive differences
between people who believe we're going
to die in people who don't good I love
it you think of like a like a
scientifically here but uh and they have
actually answers like there's a whole
Terror management Theory where they do
type write psychology type papers and
they do actual experiments I can mention
how their methodology is interesting
um they Prime with the discussion of
death like they take one certain set of
people and have a conversation with them
another set of people they mentioned
death to them before the conversation
and see how that affects their uh the
nature of the conversation it's really
interesting because death fundamentally
Alters
the nature of the conversation just even
priming
to come like reminding you that you're
going to die briefly changes changes a
lot of things these kinds of priming
papers usually not replicated
I just have like I feel like I've heard
a bunch of priming ones that
I think you have PTSD over psychology
papers it's not replicated I just did
one I just did a primary experiment on
my own and found it didn't have any
effect
but again can't you just give me okay
Carol a statement summarizing an entire
scientific discipline of Terror
management Theory I don't know uh I
think people should like I haven't
rigorously looked at how good of it
psychologically I think okay it is
interesting philosophically the way
Freud talked about the the subconscious
mind philosophically it's an interesting
discussion then you have to get rigorous
with it for sure
um but
the idea is that
like it's not that religious people
get rid of the terror of death
this is just one of the popular ways
they create an illusion on top of it
that's that idea like a myth that allows
that makes it easier for them to forget
to escape that Terror but everybody else
does different
different methods like
you feel your days with like capitalism
has a whole it's a whole religion of
itself like the rat race for getting
more and more material possessions and
so on and couldn't you argue in the
opposite direction like let's say assume
that we're Christians here and we're
like oh the atheists you know everybody
has Terror of hell and the atheists
invent this mythology where you know
actually evolution is true in order to
escape their Terror of hell so it
doesn't feel like a persuasive argument
to me but I used to be very very
Christian and I did not have a terror of
death and then I lost my faith and then
I had a deep Terror of death set in for
a few years and it felt very different
to me so for denial of death I don't
know if he says that it's actually
possible without
really a lot of work to get to the
actual Terror like I think his claims
that in early early early childhood
development
that's when the terror is real
and then we come aggressively construct
systems around it of social interaction
to to um
to support to sort of construct
illusions at the top of it I'm doing a
half-assed description of this
philosophy but there is like it isn't
interesting to simplify
the human mind into underlying
mechanisms that drive it
yeah I was gonna say your thinking seems
kind of poetic like the way that you're
sort of handling these yeah these
Concepts feel like more like
aesthetically driven I think this theme
is going to continue throughout this
conversation as we talk about
relationships and sex yes for sure I
think so and I think you're thinking
seems to be very driven by how can I
construct an experiment
to test this hypothesis yeah something
like that yeah but aren't there's some
things especially that have to do with
the human mind that are really messy
really difficult to understand there's
so many uncertainties and Mysteries
around that we don't yet have the tools
to collect the data like one of your
favorite tools is the survey is asking
people questions
and then figuring out different ways to
indirectly get at the truth because
there's flaws to the survey and you you
kind of learn about those flaws and you
get better and better asking the right
questions and so on but that's not
that's indirect access to the human mind
but do you think like Poetic narratives
are I'm not like saying poetic
narratives are bad like I think it's
like a cool way of like handling
Concepts but I'm not sure that they are
more rigorous no no no okay no but like
they might be
the more correct like philosophy might
be the right way to discuss things that
were really far from understanding yeah
I mean they might be more useful
shorthand yeah like morality like I
don't think morality makes any sense but
it's really useful shorthand to use when
handling Concepts and a lot of the time
right like ethics and morality you could
construct studies that ask different
questions like uh you know just having
worked with the autonomous vehicles a
lot the uh the trolley problem gets
brought up and I don't know you can
construct all kinds of interesting
surveys about the trolley problem but
does that really get at some deep
moral calculus that humans do it's sexy
because people like write clickbait
articles about it but does it really get
to like what you value more five
grandmas or like three children or
whatever like they construct these
arguments of like if you could steer a
train if you could steer an autonomous
car which do you choose
yeah I don't know I don't know if it's
possible with some of those to construct
like sometimes the fuzzy area
there's some topics that are fuzzing
will forever be fuzzy
given our limited cognitive capabilities
I don't know there's a way of looking at
things where it's like for example the
childhood fetish thing that I was
talking about like departed your
footages come from like you can develop
a narrative where it's like you know I
think like this kind of thing is you
know you're surrounded by feet when
you're a child this causes foot fetishes
um and this is like kind of a cool
narrative uh and I think a lot of
people's ideas about philosophy follow
the same sort of thing like what is the
narrative that is cool and I think this
is useful for meaning making like I'm
very Pro meaning making like when you're
talking about everything is uh fun
because you know the contrast or
whatever I've very much just ascribed to
that I really enjoy that that philosophy
I also find everything to be very
delightful uh but and this isn't like a
question of truth right we're not like
where is the true Delight that we're
objectively measuring I guess there's a
frame a poetic frame that you're using
to like sort of change the way the light
hits the world around you and that's
super useful because it like makes you
happier
or something
yeah but also gets
to the truth or something
yeah I guess what is the truth
um yet another question what is truth
you've uh
actually to jump back you don't you
believe that Free Will is an illusion um
so uh
why does it feel like
I'm free to make any decision I want
well it's a cool illusion I think it's
probably like where a sense of identity
oh like when you really meditate on your
sense of identity for at least for me it
seems like it comes down to the sense of
choice like oh I am doing the thinking
like what does it mean to do with
thinking it's like ah something in me
has
exerted agency over having this thought
or not having this thought
like the sense of self really comes down
to choice and so when I say that like
free will listen illusion I also mean
there's something like the selfish
illusion identity is
a trick of the light
but it's a really fun one yeah you think
a lot about your identity
I have occasionally yeah like you really
struggle with it you're proud of it I I
do too it's not we have different
Journeys but so I really take a lot of
delight in it I used to be very into
like deconstructing it like you probably
you know I did a bunch of like way too
much LSD for a while and at that point
very no no ego and now I'm like very ego
I really enjoy having a lot of ego
I actually happen to know like
everything about you really yeah like
more than you do it's interesting that's
fascinating wait could you could you
solve my problems yes all of them I've
did thorough research okay
um
what is consciousness then
I actually wrote that as a question what
is consciousness
to remind myself so like uh how's that
tie in together with Free Will and
identity and all of that it doesn't mean
what his Consciousness is like one of
the biggest questions ever I think I I
do think that people often get confused
when talking about Consciousness because
I think people are referring to two
separate Concepts and often like
combining them into one thing like we
asked the question you know is AI going
to be conscious
um I think this is kind of the wrong
question like uh like like we can
identify signs of Consciousness like ah
they seem to refer to themselves but
this is not necessarily proof of
Consciousness in the same way that like
dream characters
acting exactly the way normal human do
people do in your dream is not evidence
that they themselves are conscious so
like signs of Consciousness are not
proof of Consciousness but there is
something that we definitely know which
is like I currently am conscious I can
tell because
right like I'm like just directly
observing my experience yeah uh and so
like there's one kind of Consciousness
which is I am directly observing my
experience and that you cannot replicate
it like there I cannot observe two
experiences uh it is necessarily
singular and it is necessarily certain
like you can make all the arguments you
want like I'm still directly observing
it's not a thing that's subject to
reason whereas are other things
conscious this is something that's
replicable like you can apply it to
multiple people
um it's something that's not certain uh
like almost definitionally not certain
like we don't actually know if there is
you know an internal experience so my
argument is that like when people are
talking about other things having
experienced they're using a different
concept than the thing that they're
actually looking at when they look at
their own experience I think they're two
different things
definitionally not possible no if you
understand the mechanism of
Consciousness you'll be able to measure
it probably right yeah but what are you
measuring like I think this is like a
subtle difference like when you're
asking the quest is other thing
conscious
yeah the easy thing to measure is like a
survey does this thing appear conscious
yeah and then the hard thing is you
understand the actual mechanism of how
Consciousness arises
in the physics of the people do that in
a dream presumably like if you had a
very good dream or a very good
simulation yeah but we could then have
somebody in a simulation or a dream
where they go through and they fully
understand you know they do all the
tests and the tests come back exactly
they'd expect them to uh but from the
outside we're like well this is
misleading they're not actually
conscious
like your dream characters aren't
conscious right probably I don't know
are you asking are you telling I'm like
appealing to an intuition
but it sounds like you're driving
towards a narrative I don't you you did
a poll about men and women and Dreams
yeah those are some kind of difference I
couldn't tell what the difference was
except that more men than women quite a
lot more women dream vividly than men oh
which I actually found my chaos survey
it's like I did a survey maybe you know
that I said I don't know everything you
do know yes I'm sorry so as you clearly
know I'll try not to talk down to this
conversation because I don't know and I
not only know everything I know how your
future looks like really and every how
everything ends yeah so you could
probably win all the prediction markets
on my life yeah cool so well we should
also mention that you have like
prediction markets uh you have like
votes that you what what's the site
called again manifold manifold and one
of them was will I be on the Lex
Friedman podcast yeah and I voted I
invested everything I own into the yes
is there such thing as Fighters radio on
there is that it goes against the terms
no I think inside attorney is part of
the information so it's supposed to be
and then I realized it's actually public
information that I voted because like I
think my face shows up there's like damn
it it's gonna influence
you could make the fake account or I
could be lying right yeah and then dump
the stuff you know I try to manipulate
somebody made a market like is Ayla
going to post a poll spelled p-o-l-e on
her Twitter like a photo and I was like
I'm gonna manipulate this market so I
like [__] around with it and I voted
no and I accidentally posted a photo of
a poll without thinking
sabotage I yeah I accidentally yeah the
fact that my own Market that doesn't
that's like the reverse of Insider
training yeah uh what were we talking
about oh the women and the men and the
difference the vivid dreams
and the markets I forget what the market
oh because I can I can perfectly predict
your future yeah then it's not fun I
like the road mass of unpredictability
and so I I like to even though I know
everything I like to forget everything
yeah very very Buddhist of you yeah the
river no no man in the river once
whatever the footsteps however that's
one of my uh favorite questions is like
if you could press a button and then
have all of your wants fulfilled
anything that you want so it's like such
a rapid degree that you don't really
experience the one like as the wander
Rises it then is like completed
immediately so that you are completely
without want like would you would you
press that button 100 not yeah I didn't
think you would no no you know because
immediately everything stops being fine
the first it's only fun the first time
but if you want it to be fun but like
what will be my source of fun I feel
like I would like on day four just to
get off I would need to like do like
nuclear war because it'll escalate
quickly
I feel like if everything is possible I
assume you mean like something that like
is not just normal human things yeah
magical world magical world then you
start escalating really quickly
like I wonder I'll probably do like I
want everybody to just fly into the air
and hover in the air
I love you everybody and then you're
like oh
life is meaningless like why does like
you you go I feel like you get
uh no I actually that'd be a really
interesting experiment like what are the
limits like are we all capable of
becoming Psychopaths essentially
like
I like to believe not there's a very
hard limits on that like in our own mind
like of basic compassion because I love
being compassionate towards other human
beings it's one of the things I think
about if you give me power like a lot of
power like absolute power and I think
that's the power you mentioned is the
scariest kind of power because it's like
it's not even power in this normal world
it's like magical power where you lose
it's a dream world power where you like
video game Power you don't even think of
it as reality you could just mess with
the world I feel like that's terrifying
yeah basically be God
yeah but without like
I feel like the idea of God wants to
like gonna keep things like
functioning properly but then you would
probably if you wanted to keep them
functioning properly yeah then it would
rapidly like you would never experience
a time where you're like oh no that was
a mistake because as soon you like
before you even experience that the
world would shift to to match it oh
interesting now I think I would actually
I take it back I think I would regret
the first time I hurt somebody
see in my visualization was like a video
game where everybody's like NPC really
dumb no I think the first time I I
witnessed paying from anybody that's
when I would stop and I would probably
run into that very quickly
like even just the hovering make a
person hover and they're gonna be
probably really upset with the hovering
right and so I'm gonna be like no don't
do that anymore and then I'll probably
go to honestly I'll just return back to
my normal life
uh yeah that's kind of what I feel like
like if I had the power to do anything I
think I would probably want to have a
life very similar to where I am now yeah
yeah I mean there's it's like with Uber
like it'd be probably more convenient to
do certain things
but even then
like the struggle like I got a flat tire
so I have to fix that I kind of the flat
tire makes
makes everything more beautiful was that
cool I could do like a normal manual
thing
uh but also it makes you like appreciate
your car appreciate Transportation
appreciate the convenience the
transportation all of it I I know some
people who would like call this a bunch
of copium like you're just sort of
making do with what you have like we
wouldn't go back to Amish times or like
pre-technology because to like in order
to make ourselves appreciate things more
and so it seems like a hindsight
reasoning uh which like I can appreciate
that argument but I don't know I'm like
anyone who uses sorry to interrupt the
word copium in their um in their
argumentation
um uh I think it's sauce
yeah it's that's my entire argument is
now no I'm just kidding I'm sorry go
ahead sorry I interrupted rudely the
flow of thought uh but you you so you
don't think so in part you disagree with
that kind of argument
um
yeah because I I think people have this
idea that if you uh like come to accept
or like Find meaning in what you have
now this is sort of at odds with trying
to improve it
and all right I don't find this to be
the case I find like the attempt to
improve it to also be part of it like I
enjoy the fact that there's something
like problematic going on because now I
get the experience of like striving to
make it go away and like that in itself
is where the meaning lies it's not just
that things are bad it's that there's
things are bad and we're trying to stop
it and also exactly there's if you
combine that with a sense of optimism
that the future can be better yeah that
feeds
feeds into this productive effort of
making things better
and it somehow makes the vision of the
things that are better more intense
having experienced shitty things
yeah
so we talked about Free Will and
Consciousness and what drives human
civilization question left unanswered
it's a homework problem for the reader
okay
let's get like a scoreboard at the end
the amount of questions the answer
successfully versus not like polls yeah
can we talk about some practical things
sure
uh so one of the many amazing things I
think of you as a researcher but you've
also been
uh doing research in the field yeah
field work good field work the Jane
Goodall love
yeah
uh how did you get uh what's the the
short and the long story of how you got
into sex work how did I get into sex
work well I mean there's a whole like
childhood thing where I was
conservatively homeschooled uh do you
want to actually talk about your
childhood I think it's interesting
because you also worked at a factory
it's like your childhood is really
fascinating uh and difficult uh
traumatic so um and you've written about
it
there's a lot of ways we can talk about
it but maybe
what are the things you remember
the good and the bad of your childhood
of your maybe interaction with your
father
yeah my dad probably has narcissistic
personality disorder and so it was very
centered on very controlling childhood
immensely so
um we were homeschooled and pretty
isolated from the outside world like we
didn't know anybody else who wasn't
homeschooled we went through a program
called Growing Kids God's way which was
very is like the kind of program where
you're not supposed to pick up babies
when they cry to train them that they
can't manipulate the parents because
like baby crying was viewed as like uh
you're just teaching them from an early
age that they're allowed to make the
parents do what the kids want yeah and
they're very against this philosophy so
you know that combined with a
narcissistic personality disorder dad
was pretty rough
uh it's a controlling super controlling
yeah and developing and feeding the
self-critical aspect of your brain yeah
very much it was you know I was like
lazy but I was never going to accomplish
anything in life it's gonna move out of
the house and realize how good I had it
at home you know the classic stuff uh he
was very like logical and smart though
and so he'd also like teach us
logic stuff I remember some of my
earliest memories or him like giving me
basic logic puzzles like the dog has
three legs you know how many dogs the
four legs and I I would mess up and
uh but he was he was a evangelist
basically a Christian evangelist so we
like Bible study five nights a week I
memorized I think 800 verses of the
Bible by the time before I became an
adult
um
yeah and it was very patriarchal also I
was expected to grow up and become a
housewife basically they're like oh you
can go to college to meet a man and also
to get a little bit of education so that
you can homeschool your own kids like we
were explicitly told that women were
subordinate to men
um in regards to like making decisions
when you're married our pastor's
daughter was not allowed to leave home
because she would be outside of the
authority of a man so when she got
married she was allowed to leave because
she was never allowed to live in a house
where she was not under a hierarchy this
is like the kind of culture that that we
live so there's a hierarchy and uh the
gender aspect to the hierarchy is men at
the top of that hierarchy men at the top
okay but you're on psychology your own
mind
um so most of that self-critical brain
is bad right it was confusing because he
told me that I was smart but also that I
would fail
uh but I I I'm not smart enough right or
like smart but not smart enough smart
but like not virtuous or something okay
so okay right there's always a flaw yeah
there's always a flaw I think a lot of
it was a lot of the the [__] upness of
my brain came from feeling like I didn't
have the authority to think because it
was so like carefully like suppressed
like the my ability to like Express or
have any sort of power was just
absolutely annihilated like systemically
like psychologically they would do like
psychological torture mechanisms to make
sure that like I wasn't actually
thinking on my own or like being able to
deviate from anything anybody ever told
me to the degree that it's still
ingrained in me like I once was a friend
we were traveling and he wanted me to
hop a turnstile it was like very late at
night the train was here and I could not
physically force myself to do it like he
was like yelling me like come on do it
like like no but I was trying so hard to
make my body across the line and it was
just it's like embedded in my physical
being to like be unable to do stuff like
that which is really annoying that
you're not free to take action in this
world yeah some
so it's that that was I think the most
annoying part of the my upbringing
would you classify it as like suffering
at the time yeah definitely well it's
confusing because like when when I was a
child it was it was just painful in the
sense that like things suck but it was
placed in a meaning framework right like
it is good it is virtuous to submit to
your parents and do what they want if
they tell you to say goodbye to your
best friend forever and ever talk to
them again you go do that without
complaining and so like I would go do
something like that and I would like it
would suck it really was like concretely
painful but it was also placed in this
narrative where I was like fulfilling
some sort of Greater purpose sure uh and
so so it's very confusing to refer to it
as suffering because there's so many
painful things we do today that are
placed in The Narrative of a greater
purpose that like I think I would agree
with like I go get a medical procedure
done that sucks but I'm like ah this is
helping me in the long run but like say
if I got abducted to an alien planet and
they're like by the way all of those
medical procedures you got done like you
didn't have to get them done those are
totally unnecessary then I might get
really upset about it yeah I wouldn't
trust those aliens though because they
probably want to do different medical
procedures I saw I saw some I saw a
thumbnail for a video that I'm proud of
myself for not clicking on about a man
who's claimed that he had sex with
aliens
and I was like for not clicking on that
because I was wondering because because
that I would probably watch it for like
20 minutes and then I should be doing
work oh I see so like I and I I and I'm
actually happy because I get to imagine
what it all the different possibilities
that could have been for that man who
was like a really high like resting
happiness State yes yeah it's probably
like a mushroom State yeah wow do you do
mushrooms I've done mushrooms before it
was very awesome
but like more intensely awesome
but but like like because I was just
looking at nature it makes nature even
more beautiful I think but it's already
it's already pretty beautiful I haven't
done MDMA
um
people say that I I should it's very
nice yeah yeah anyway
um but I'm already yeah what did you
call it resting happiness day yeah
harvesting happening happiness
yeah that's a good that's a good way to
describe it but it's not like some of
it's genetic that you're able to notice
the beauty in the world and some of it
is practiced where you realize focusing
on the negative things in life
like unproductively is uh
it's it just doesn't help your mind
flourish so like you just notice that
and it's like
I mean I think people with like
depression uh learn that or like
probably with trauma too is like there's
certain triggers like if you're if you
suffer from depression you have to kind
of consciously know there's going to be
triggers that will expire like force you
to spiral down and so just avoid those
triggers some people have that with diet
with food and so on and so I just don't
like whenever there's uh shitty things
happening or Shady people
unless I can help on this unless I can
do somehow hope like why why focus on it
yeah anyway uh
back to you upbringing what uh
what was the Journey of escaping that
um I well I left home like kind of early
um because my my dad and I were not
getting along by the time I was a
teenager
um but I still Christian for a while and
I lost my faith after I think I moved it
away and I started having friends that
weren't religious or like weren't raised
in the super conservative environment
that I came from and I think uh I this
was not conscious at the time this was
my hindsight story but I believe that
like being exposed to a culture in which
I had the capacity to believe like
allowed my brain to actually seriously
consider the thought that maybe all of
this stuff was untrue that I'd been
taught like six thousand year old Earth
and evolution is a lie you know macro
Evolution and all of this stuff uh
because like when you're when you're in
immersed in an environment like that I
don't think you actually have a choice
like your brain has to believe these
things because this is a survival thing
like if you believe this you'll be com
like if you believe the wrong thing
you'll be totally cast out even if
they're not gonna cast you out you're
going to be cast out in like communion
with others because we're always told
that you can't like trust non-believers
really they don't have a moral compass
they're going to screw you over and so
I'm like oh I can't beat that like
everybody's gonna Outcast me internally
yeah so anyway I wasn't I don't think I
actually had the capacity to seriously
question my faith even though I thought
that I was questioning it quite hard
until I got into an environment where it
was safe to do so and once I started
being able to make friends who were not
religious I'm like oh if I lose my faith
I'm still going to have some sort of
community
um and then at that time I went through
some questioning and then I lost my
faith and
so in that given your friends giving you
a situation you have you you now have
the freedom to think essentially or at
least the ability to think of something
that was acceptable in the new culture
yeah
without
I mean is there a danger of like
adopting the beliefs of the new culture
so like there's some aspect of just
being able to think freely which you
weren't able to do when you were growing
up just to think like look at the world
and wonder how it works that kind of
thing but I mean you rip it within
certain boundaries like there's certain
basic assumptions
and as long as you're following those
basic assumptions which is to be fair
it's like kind of what we're doing now
like we have I have I gone and done the
personal research that like evolution is
the thing that's going on have I looked
at like the age of the stones no I
haven't I'm trusting other people yeah
uh which I think is like a fair choice
to make given where I'm at right now but
you're also assuming like
there's causality in the universe time
is real yeah that like that first of all
the thing that your senses are
perceiving is real
you're assuming a lot of things
I'm aware of the assumptions you're
making like as opposed to not making
those assumptions at all like you have
to assume something and I did it's very
suspicious right that I went out of this
very conservative culture and now I well
I guess I don't believe things that are
super in line with the current culture I
think this is why I feel a little bit
safer right now because like when I was
Christian I believe generally Christian
thanks but now I believe a bunch of
things that like people really hate like
I get canceled online all the time I'm
like okay this is a sign that maybe
you're thinking independently if you're
like able to think things that are
completely at odds with the people
around you and and to be fair this is a
little bit easier to do when it's like
General culture but it's much harder to
do with your peer group like the people
that you trust your friends the people
whose opinions you respect like
disagreeing with those people is very
difficult and I'm not very good at it
yeah I do think that if you establish
yourself as a person who can be trusted
and is a good human being you have a lot
more freedom
to then explore ideas that are different
from your peer group so like those seem
like if you separate the space of ideas
versus some kind of like deeper sense of
what this person is
like that that this they're an
interesting and trustworthy and good
human being well like do
somebody that you respect to you because
they're significantly smarter than you
and can you imagine believing an idea
that you've heard them talk really
disdainfully about like how would you
feel coming to me like I believe this
thing that you find to be
yeah I do all the time oh yeah yeah you
may be braver than me
and Jamaica I support doing this like I
try to do this but I think like like
subconsciously I noticed that I'm I
don't do it as much and so I'm
suspicious of myself I'm like oh I
wonder if I'm hiding to myself like
actual curiosity about things that might
deviate from my peer group because I
noticed that I'm not actually deviating
with them as much as I do with the
outside world yeah it's a Jimmy like
because I do see most people I interact
with are smarter than me but I also have
this intuitive feeling that uh dumb
people which I consider myself being
have wisdom
so like in the disagreement actually I
also believe in the power of
conversation and in the tension of this
agreement so I think I even just
disagreeing from a place
from a good place from from a place of
like love and respect for each other I
think I just believe in that so it's not
like individuals you're disagreeing
you're like working towards arriving at
some deeper truth together right even if
the other person is is uh
is smarter maybe that's maybe that's how
I justify for myself I just I'm also a
fan of conversations because like I've
seen just listening to conversations
it seems like a great conversation more
emerges from it than the sum of its
parts right like somehow two people
together can do
like that dance of ideas can somehow
create
um create a cool thing by the way I
enjoyed I saw a video of you dancing
at a bar drunk
it wasn't the bar drunk it didn't look
drunk but just the dancing it was like
ballroom dancing type of thing I was
like yeah something like that I've been
doing a bit of Tango dancing I like it
Argentine nice I like stuff with the
body in general like uh like wrestling
or combat like usually when there's
attention you have to understand the
mechanics of how two bodies move when
they're in conflict and dancing is
it's similar like you have to do like
rapid thinking also like rapid intuitive
physical thinking and that's my favorite
kind of thing like a lot of exercise is
really boring to me because you can just
do it while your brain's off but
something like ballroom dancing or
Fusion dancing like you have to
constantly be like figuring out like
it's a rapid puzzle and that's so
beautiful what's Fusion dancing that's
the video that's the effusion dancing is
like if you have any sort of dance
background you can come and you just
kind of mix those together speaking
about people like ballet with people
doing ballroom with people doing Blues
cool and then there's an interesting
dynamic because there's I don't know
maybe you can correct me but there's uh
that's very meta there's usually a lead
in the follow
I guess most dances have that yeah yeah
and so that but both have a different
like you both have to be quite sensitive
to the other human being but in a
different way
yeah it's interesting yes so I like both
that there is that definitive role
but also
like it's not somehow that one is better
than the other there's an interesting
tension between the two yeah yeah it's
cool because it's like a basic rule set
that allows for a ton of expression I've
recently started to experience
experiment with like reverse leading
it's not like back leading it's like I
don't know like sometimes I was like
what I'm typically following I'll like
occasionally throw in a little lead here
and there but don't but don't you kind
of always oh I see but don't you hit
hint at
a lead when you're following
I can't don't you just by the the
Dynamics of your movement you're not
perfectly following I mean because there
is like the lead is listening to your
body right yeah so like
you're kind of both figuring out what
you do next that's true I'm a very good
follow though okay so I'm like I'm like
I'm an invisible follower you do a move
it's like a oh interesting I'm not good
at Tech I didn't know those existed like
a perfect father
I really I do I'm I'm not great at
technique and sometimes I'll fall over
but like with The Following part I'm
very good at it do you enjoy yeah yeah
it's really nice if it's again like it's
a very fast physical puzzle you have to
solve it's like typing I really like
typing so I was inquiring about your
keyboard earlier why are you like typing
because it's like the very fast like the
really rapid response what's the
reaction time I like things that like
have very fast reaction times like games
like that
but typing is not a reaction or is it
the brain generating words and then
you're like cause typing a reaction okay
The Sensation that I get when I am
typing is the kind of thing that I'm
trying to point out so maybe maybe a
reaction time isn't the quite I don't
know what the term is but whatever that
thing is like the thing where you have
to like look at a word and then
communicate it into your fingers yeah
it feels like dancing like you're
responding you're responding to your
brain your fingers are doing the
responding to the brain to generate the
words yeah
making your body do what your brain
wants it to do but like fast and
precisely well then you might not like
this Kinesis keyboard because it makes
the it makes it easier to do that you
probably like the struggle right no you
well I mean that it looks hard because
you have it looks like it's high
depression on the keys no it's well oh I
see yes more than more than like a
laptop keyboard but like
that you don't have to one of the the
main things is you don't have to move
your fingers at all
So like
um so like for example a lot of people
that I think they have a backspace up in
the top right corner yeah so if you have
to make mistakes which is like
I mean that's like so metaphorical like
every mistake you have to like really
hurt yourself for if you have to like
stretch for the backspace this
is like a lot of your perspectives yeah
no uh
yeah I don't and I see it as as a good
thing it's a good like a
a romantic element permeates my
interpretation of the world yes but you
uh you left home early
how did you end up working at a factory
well I tried to go to college but failed
couldn't afford it
did you like it
I remember it just being really slow I
remember being shocked that the teachers
didn't care like I was used to
homeschooling yeah and and where I don't
know like educate it just like it meant
something they felt like the people
around me that were teaching me because
we had like a mom's group also like
directly cared about what I was learning
and I would be able to ask questions and
they would like really respond to mom's
group and it was like a homeschooling
groups there were a bunch of moms who
are homeschooling their kids get
together
and then teach each other's kids
oh cool yeah and they have different
like interests and capabilities and so
on and they kind of and sometimes if
some of the kids are really good at
something you have like the older kids
teaching the other ones too so it was
very like everybody kind of figures out
what they're good at and they should
share that skill set with everybody else
which I think was a pretty great setup
honestly I think my childhood kind of
sucked in a lot of ways but
homeschooling was excellent for me
mainly because it just had so much free
time like I was just did like two to
three hours of school and then did
whatever the [__] I wanted for the rest
of the day and I got to actually pursue
skills that are still useful for me to
this day so
even in that constrained environment
like I wrote I read fantasy books and I
wrote so much and now I'm now I'm
writing a lot on my blog so what kind of
fantasy books like sci-fi type stuff
um like classic like I read
um like Mercedes Lackey and uh the ee
Knight and um arsell the Gwen and I
don't know any of this what is this what
is it is like a romantic thing is it
like is it romance it's all the fantasy
books like dragons oh dragons
you didn't mention Tolkien for the
fantasy I read I read Tolkien okay yeah
all right well it's beautiful so you you
uh throw all the dragons
uh how did you end up in a factory you
tried school yeah yeah try school had to
drop off a couple months and then I was
like well I'm poor and uh I was I was
trying to take any job I was like
applying for sewer jobs and then I got a
factory I'm like because my parents know
no financial help at all they're like
you pull yourself up by your own
bootstraps you know
so anyway I went to work at a factory
and that sucks ass do not recommend we
had to work up wake up like 4 a.m you
know work on weekends too
fluorescent lights it was terrible and
so I did that for about a year and I was
like this is I was trying to grip my
teeth and be like this is my life right
I didn't have high expectations for my
life I was just like I thought like if
you get a job where you don't have to be
on your feet all the time that's that
you're living a good life but and then I
got another job briefly as a
photographer and then they fired me I
think I was 19 at the time
fired you for like I was just I was just
too young the end really really bad at
interacting with people in the outside
world like I was pretty well socialized
as a homeschooler with other
homeschoolers but in the outside world
especially with all of the like
hierarchy submissions stuff beaten into
me like literally beaten into me it was
very difficult for me to interact with
other people who were like older than me
or had any sort of confidence at all so
they hired me to do like photography for
people and then I was rapidly turned out
that I was bad at this and so they fired
me but at that point I'd left my factory
job I'm like I can't go back to the
factory so I tried I had some savings
and I slept on Friends couches and I
tried various self-employment stuff I'm
like maybe I can do product photography
or
something but no it's Idaho you know
nothing and if you're like a 19 year old
no experience in the outside world at
all it was really difficult and so I had
a friend recommend that I try being
humming a cam girl so that's how it
started what's what what is uh what is
Cami what is being a cam girl Kimmy is
like you talk to the camera live on the
computer like you live streams kind of
like twitch and then people are typing
in the chat like huh do this stuff and
then the people can tip you money and
then you can do things in response like
oh if you took me 100 tokens you know
I'll take my shirt off or something like
that and like what's the what site were
you using at that time my free camps my
free cams is that a popular site that's
pretty popular okay and how did um what
were the next steps like did you enjoy
it
oh well it was the first time I had
actual control over my life
and I made like actual real money and so
I just exploded into it I thought about
it non-stop I was streaming all the time
I was like coming with like new creative
things and the thing is like I don't
know I there's something about public
school that I I ended up living in a
house with Cam Girls full of other girls
who'd gone to public school and I don't
know if how much of his genetic or like
just because I'm weird or is it because
of our upbringing but I felt like I was
much more fearless and much more weird
and creative online than other people
were not because they weren't awesome
people but because I think like public
school I got the impression based on
them talking about it that sort of like
beats out any sort of deviance from you
like it more so than your because I I
got the oh we had moral deviants was
beaten out but like you could do
whatever creative deviants crazy this
wasn't so much like I didn't have other
kids making fun of me ever I didn't I
don't think I'd ever heard an insult
about my physical appearance as a child
or a teenager once so your father was
basically saying you're not good enough
was intellectual oh no that was like a
moral failure moral failure yeah like I
was not virtuous
wow like in various ways like you know
like you're lazy and mostly the lazy
part because I have like I have like
ADHD or something uh yeah and it was I
was not good at it as a kid either I
would totally forget all the time and
is there some sexual repression aspect
to that like uh you know how they say
that there's um it's it's not just
homeschooling but just like Catholic
girls and so on just because like
there's moral you're forbidden to do
certain things like there's a kind of
liberating feeling of saying
like basically rediscoving yourself or
discovering a Freedom by doing just uh
diving head in head first into sexuality
into your own sexuality is there some
aspect of that yeah absolutely to some
degree I think that like people kind of
model it slightly wrong like I think
there's a truth to it but when I first
got out of the house for me Freedom was
like going outside at 2AM yeah or like
eating chocolate you know on days that I
previously wasn't allowed to eat
chocolate like that was like a really
intense expression of rebellion for me
and I think people like don't think of
this like like I got out a lot of my
like intense Rebellion through things
that people don't typically consider to
be rebellious at all sure like I wore a
bikini yeah insane uh I just like walked
around in it and like
I can do this yeah
and so like this was most of that
emotional processing for me
um and I took me a couple years from
leaving home and all of that
conservative culture into doing sex work
in in the meantime I was I did try
having sex with a lot of people but this
was mainly because I didn't know what
the Norms were I didn't really
understand I was just like okay take
things logically take things one step at
a time I'm like okay if the whole
previous set about like how I'm not
supposed to kiss somebody until the
altar of marriage if that's not the way
that things are supposed to go then what
is the way things are supposed to go and
I was like well if I am aroused I should
go have sex with someone right is there
any reason not to no so I went I just I
would go around asking random people to
have sex with me did you have any peer
pressure saying like that's not good or
that is good or like any did you feel
any currents of society in any direction
this part are you independently just
thinking like for from first principles
I think I mean like I'm not saying it
was a totally a clean thing I'm sure
that I was experiencing Society telling
me this is bad but you have to know like
I wasn't watching normal movies when I
was a teen like we watched Christian
movies we are the stuff that we watched
was filtered like I watched the Titanic
and I had no idea that Jack and Rose had
sex because it was put through uh
filtered wait did they yeah they went
and you know he painted her naked and
yeah yeah there's a scene in a car
cars and storage and these there's a
hand I watched it again later and I was
like I don't know what the sex scene
well maybe were you also put through uh
maybe it's the filter I see like did the
couple in the notebook also have sex
because maybe for romantic movies I
focus on the romance
maybe right and the sex scenes are
always like weirdly filmed in these yeah
because it's never I mean
it doesn't it feels more like romance
and sex
I guess that's the main focus of this
right yeah yeah that makes sense yeah
anyway so they had sex it's good to know
they did I'll go back and and watch you
have your own effects filter on your
brain and once you realize that there
are some uh like the foundation of your
beliefs
were wrong then everything might be
wrong and you're kind of just doing yeah
principles basically and again like not
totally separate from culture but also I
think in general I also have a
predisposition to just be like you know
[__] what culture tells you just figure
out what's right for you and do it and
so that mixed with you know the figuring
things out from first principles I did
eventually figure out that I didn't like
having casual sex with just anybody
quite as much so I stopped that but it
took me a while to figure that out
what's the negative of casual sex it's
just like not good I mean the
you're at the chemistry you have with
someone better then then it can be a lot
nicer but I wasn't doing that I was just
like somebody I met and I'm like you
seem kind of cute okay like I didn't
bother to try and develop just any
chemistry I mean I didn't chemistry even
outside of sex just chemistry like human
chemistry conversation yeah okay I would
I would I'm it's like kind of cringy but
I would like I would like walk up to
guys or send them messages like would
you like to have coitus is what I would
say you would say quarters I said that
I mean it's kind of it's kind of cute in
a way I mean it's a girl asking you to
get laid so they probably didn't care
that much
anyway I'm saying that like I had a lot
of rebellion out of my system by the
time I started sex work yeah
um so like for me like maybe I'm sure it
was somehow related because we were
extremely sexually repressed growing up
I remember the day I learned I had a
vagina which was absolutely horrifying
uh do not recommend figuring out you
have another orifice in your body
um but like do you want to share the
process of you figuring out that you had
a vagina because they told me I had a
vagina oh like intellectually like there
was somebody said you have your vagina
vagina yeah and that was horrifying to
you yeah
I didn't know I had because you weren't
supposed to ever like touch or look at
yourself ever so I never did it was
really disgusting
and so I had no idea that what was going
on in my genital region and so one day
my mom sat me down I think it was like
nine or ten
and she was like you have a there's
another what
and you're going to bleed out of it is
what she told me well you're gonna bleed
out of it for a while and I was like
what the [__] mom
I didn't know the word [__] was but I
would have said that if I had known when
did you first learn the word [__] oh I
think I learned it when I was at a
playground and it was written somewhere
and I read it out loud and then a kid
next to me started giggling uh-huh did
you ever did you say [__] again for a
while no I think the next episode I I
swore the first time I was 18.
like intentionally said a swear word
when I was 18. did you feel good
I was like really nervous I was like
nervous
I mean [__] pretty good yeah it [__]
pretty good yeah
okay so uh so that's caming I mean what
are the the pros and cons of camping and
how does only fans map into this did you
switch to only fans at some point I did
yeah that came for like five or six
years and I burned out eventually what
are the good aspects what are the bad
aspects of Cami well the good aspects
were it's just your own terms you get to
decide everything about it is under your
control which I loved at the time I was
like I can work when I want how I want
any sort of expression I experimented
and I was very successful I was making
around 200 an hour which for that
website at the time was like pretty good
um I had elaborate routines I was a mime
I would do like dress up as a lime and
then dress up a chair and I would seduce
the chair
oh cool yeah or like it was almost it
was was there an artistic element to it
almost yeah very much
no I was a mime you know oh sorry uh
right yeah get it straight dude
you know what I really appreciate about
you is I'm asking some really dumb
questions and you're answering in a very
intelligent way so I appreciate that all
right did you ask the chair questions
I wasn't mine you [__] idiot okay I'm
sorry
but there's gnomes on the like big nose
or small gnomes like lawn gnomes one
gnomes and you seduced the lawn gnome on
the chair the no missing and there were
some yeah gnomes in the chair I I did a
photo set which I submitted to Reddit
where I got abducted I was like
stripping uh taking my clothes off and
then slowly the Gnomes surrounded me in
the background then dragged me off and I
did this as a photo set and I
essentially uh I mean I mean I didn't
feel consensual in the photos but okay
but it was the I'm not gonna stop us the
it was very successful in Reddit
basically is a top person Gone Wild in
the 11th top post of all time which I
think will probably just means it's like
it's it's artistic it's interesting it's
IG it's funny it's also really really
well done but it was really shocking to
be that nobody else was doing anything
creative with sex work like for me it
was it was like breathing like you're
just doing sex and you're bored I'm like
what do you do I don't know let's try
something funny like it's just the
natural progression and it felt to me
like there was almost no competition
like I would just be really creative and
like immediately lose the top not safe
for post on Reddit I'm like well I
didn't even try that it and so it's
really shocking to me that other women
who are doing this sort of thing is that
uh still a little bit of the case
that there's not as much like because I
for my sort of outside of perspective
that seems to be still the case like
there's not like as you describe it
that's kind of cool that's like almost
like
playing like having fun with sexuality
almost yeah that's and yeah but that
does require kind of thinking through
it's almost like a creative project like
a like a photography project or
something like that almost like a little
skit movie it's interesting is this Vibe
of like how can you like bring like
vibrant novelty to whatever you're doing
anything you're doing and I really like
doing this with surveys too like I've
been doing a lot of standard surveys but
I'm also like experimenting with novel
creative artistic surveys I'm like how
do you ask a question in a way that's
like beautiful and unusual and like a
thing is completely groundbreaking like
nobody's ever like you always make
everything so poetic and romantic is
disgusting now
uh but yes I think you have that engine
in your head I guess of creativity like
yeah the way you ask questions which is
not trivial to do like for uh it's
actually very difficult to do
like good survey questions and I mean
we're joking but like yeah almost like
Poetic because you have to ask a
question in a way that doesn't lead to
the answer yes like you have to
you have to kind of inspire them to
think and then indirectly get at the
truth this is very it's a it's an art
form honestly yeah and also in a way
where they don't misinterpret the
question because it's amazing how you
any question you think oh this is the
clearest question possible no you're
wrong it has to be even clearer right
willingly or unwillingly because like
you also have to defend against that
question being criticized later when you
publish about it all that you have to
think about it all I think this might be
my greatest strength so I'm not very
good at statistics I'm not like great at
presenting data but I think probably my
greatest strength is in fact survey
design and like a question phrasing
because I've I've I have treated so many
thousands of polls and every single one
I get people telling me like the way
that they misinterpreted the poll so
it's like it's like you've become gone
through fire and then again I I'm
testing the phrasings all the time like
what happens if you slightly shift
phrasings and so I'll do the same
question test over time to see how it
changes and the way the the framing
affects the results
so the good and the bad of the caming
she said good the what was it I forgot
you mean the freedom the freedom to be
also be to be creative yeah
and that is just it was exhausting the
the site that I was on the way that it
structured is that you're ranking on the
site and thus the amount of people that
see you and that's the amount of money
you are on you earn is affected by the
amount of money that you earn on average
over the last 60 days so if you're
streaming and nobody's tipping you this
means that you're going to be dropping
down in the rankings which is going to
make it harder in the future okay so the
rich get richer in that site yeah so
it's very high pressure like if you're
on you need to be making money
as fast as you can if you want to
continue to make money so that was
really stressful it was very mentally
taxing I would do it for a couple hours
and just log off and be completely
exhausted because you're just like on as
hard as you can and this is why I have a
little PTSD streaming like I've
considered Twitch streaming I try a
little bit and and I'm I'm like I
haven't fully integrated the fact that
you don't have to be like maximally
entertaining every single second yet you
can actually just chill out and take it
slow and nothing bad happens yeah yeah
you can just enjoy silence yeah
foreign
did you feel lonely
doing it
I mean even just streamers feel lonely I
moved into a house with cam girls
does that make it better or worse is it
better they're great I'm still friends
with them to this day also it was like a
team almost like we're in this kind of
together yeah so we would like working
together and you know stream together
and
swap our clothes and stuff
it was great I swap ideas too swap ideas
yeah and uh
actually on a small tangent maybe a big
tangent what do you think because it's a
recent controversy of Andrew Tate
and that he I think in the past ran a
camping business and he's being accused
of sex trafficking what do you think
like from your own experience
what do you understand about Andrew Tate
is he a good person is he a bad person
is there something Shady about his
practices or not I wish I could answer
but I don't know I haven't looked into
it at all I've heard people talking
about I just haven't bothered to go into
it it is well known that like when I was
doing it back in the day that Eastern
European models had something different
going on though it was like a Trope
about you know there's the Eastern
European battles and then there's
everybody else they're there what it's
like darker or something like they do
Studios and they're lower quality
which means what the studios are you go
into like a warehouse and then they have
set up a little like things that
replicate bedrooms yeah but they're just
like stalls
and then you give you rent out or you
pay the studio percentage of your income
and you can tell when something looks
like a studio it's like a type of
background yeah that if you're like
watching enough it kind of starts to you
notice the patterns so like the
standards are lower there in the ethical
boundaries are a little looser yeah I
thought people are treated it's Uncle we
didn't I never heard anything about the
ethical site I just knew that it was
like lower quality like the girls seemed
like they were less into it and like
Carriage less how does this all
interplay with like sex trafficking so
consensual versus non-consensual I would
be strong ER never any non-consensual
camming
um I mean I guess it's like if it were
going to happen to that point be
surprised if it were in fact Eastern
European models based on this is
outdated this is I'm just thinking of my
stereotypes back what I cammed a lot
sure so some of that is stereotyped
versus like collecting good data right
yeah I haven't done data on cam girl
it's hard I mean it's hard it's even
hard to get that data right
um yeah and obviously a really important
problem there's a method that I'm trying
that I really like I designed a survey
type which is like asking people who you
know yeah like who do you who do you
know who's done this and you tell me
like oh do you know anybody who's a
doctor do you know anybody who you know
has had cancer or like smokes or
personally I mean yeah personally just
do you know anybody yeah um and then if
you ask about a whole bunch of things
you can calibrate the responses so like
that's really interesting if you're if
your population you know 20 of them know
doctors and then you know the actual
amount of doctors then you can tell like
how this is corresponding like what is
the visibility of doctors so you can
reconstruct the graph basically yeah and
and we can do this with sex trafficking
and of course people are going to be
like well sex traffic is not visible
people you don't know those I'm like
well then we can ask about other
non-visible things that other people
don't know that we do have data for like
homelessness or being in jail or like uh
if you have been like sexually assaulted
a lot of people don't like talking about
if they've been sexually assaulted so
you can do a whole bunch of things that
are like similarly suppressed in
knowledge in some way that we do
actually have rates for and then compare
that to the graph when we ask people do
you know anybody who's in sex trafficked
yeah so again this is not perfect I'm
not saying this is for things you can
infer things about that graph but let's
say we don't have good ways of measuring
sex trafficking right now anyway I did a
big deep dive into the research that we
have and sex trafficking in the western
world and the actual like I read the
studies and like reports about the
studies and it's really pitiful we have
terrible data it's like there's just
like vague estimations made from one guy
in a basement in the 80s that's like the
basis for like one big study that like a
lot of people report on it was and so
I'm like okay so the the method I'm
proposing obviously is not perfect but
like the bar is so low at this point
well I wonder also if there's a ways to
design a survey that gets at the um at
the victims of sex trafficking also
which is they presumably have public
access to the internet and
I wonder how many of them are distinctly
aware that they're victims like it's
asking the question
when you're inside of a toxic
relationship are you inside of a toxic
relationship I mean if if the toxic
relationship is truly toxic sometimes
your your mind is [__] with right
you're not you don't even know what's
true yeah so it's interesting if you can
design surveys actively sex drive yeah
who could break through that so
basically get data on how many people
are getting sex trafficked directly oh
yeah like if you don't frame it like if
you don't say the word sex trafficking
you're like are you just in a situation
where you'd and maybe through the survey
I mean that's very meta but through the
survey help them you know I did this
this is what started my relationship
surveys so I've done a series of
relationship surveys and that was
because I knew somebody in a terrible
relationship and I was like I bet if she
took a survey where she answered
questions about her relationship and at
the end got a score that compared her to
everybody else she'd be like oh wait
everybody else has much better
relationships than I do so that's why I
started making the relationship surveys
was exactly for that reason yeah that's
really really powerful to know that like
you're not
you're not crazy for thinking this is a
bad relationship right or I think like
the actual question is like could you do
better if you broke up I think that the
thing that keeps most people in their
relationships is like this is the best
that I can do like this is normal and if
if it were normal I would say that they
are right like if you live in a culture
where everybody is abusing there there
are people in the relationships then
yeah you I mean what are you gonna do
break up and then just be alone for the
rest of your life most people don't want
to do that but not comparing yourself to
this to the average is good to know to
know no your options are at least
understand it because you know being
normal is not always like this
conversation is not always great
um
meaning this this conversation is
anything but normal okay and uh
that was a tangent on a tangent about a
niche passion which is really
fascinating that you're playing with
those kinds of ideas of uh survey design
uh but back to camming so
um what were the cons what were the
negatives of Cami oh like the exhaustion
of just like live like the high pressure
yeah that was probably the worst thing
so not was there what about the
interaction with different people like
the Dynamics of the interaction with the
with the fans I guess I had a pretty
great time I mean it obviously wasn't
perfect because it's the internet but I
don't know there's there's a this is the
thing that confuses me a lot because a
lot of women that I know complain about
being harassed by men quite a lot
they're like you know men are always you
know groping harassed you know you have
to be paranoid in the club people are
like they're always laughing on you and
there's like Jesus Christ get away man
and I do not have this experience or
like maybe I do but I'm interpreting it
differently I don't know the thing is I
don't know what causes me to have such a
different experience from these women
that are like really feel really uh
hostile towards men and my guess is that
there's some sort of like very subtle
signaling that we're accidentally doing
be like no fault of our own I'm not
saying this is a virtue I'm saying like
maybe it's just genetic or the fact that
women are doing yeah that the women are
doing yeah like that and it might be
just something I'm completely
accidentally through no intention like
happening to Signal the thing that is
causing men to not view me as like a
desirable Target or like a Target at all
what about the flip side maybe you're
not sensitive to the
the the creepy stare yeah that also
might be true the dude who's like God
like is undressing you with his eyes
that like in in a creepy way that you're
just not you don't like worry about it
you're or you're not touch like that the
fear of that the anxiety of that the the
the unpleasantness of that just doesn't
hit you I think that's also at least
part of it maybe all of it yeah yeah I
think there's there's some evidence for
it I think often like guys will do a
thing to me and I'm just like that's a
thing cool I I don't have any negative
response whatsoever that's
call back to the tire it's a thing this
is nice that happened it was good to
know that like I once had like a
homeless guy like asked me to come back
to my place baby and I was like this is
fun yeah like I'm like do you want me to
I love asking men like are you trying to
get me to have sex with you just like
saying it out front and they'll be like
well
usually they stop for a minute they're
like well uh yeah I mean I would like to
have sex and they'll be like thanks for
asking but I'm not interested in having
sex with you
and that's great I don't know I have no
issues with that interaction but like
maybe this is the kind of thing that
other women would find to be really
offensive so you have that conversation
and it doesn't turn into like a
threatening feel no like with the
homeless guy no no I've never had that
happen though but I think there's
something I think I'm doing something
like again this is kind of accidental
like I'm just am like this always and I
think I just happen to be like this at
people and they don't expect it like
they don't expect me to be like really
nice while explicitly asking them what
their intentions are like directly
putting my finger on the thing that like
oh you're trying to have sex with me and
then also not judging them for it yeah
um I think this like throws people off a
little bit so they don't get aggressive
they're like oh you're Autistic or
something even the cloak of anonymity on
the internet you weren't getting yeah I
just think I'm just not reactive and or
maybe I'm giving off I don't know I
don't know what's going on maybe it's
both maybe it's a feedback loop so I
just I had a pretty good experience I
know not everybody did definitely people
reported having antagonistic experiences
but when I was skimming I generally
really liked people are really nice to
me had a great time made friends
so you also did only fans as you
mentioned and I read on a website so
this is very investigative reporting
that uh on some months you've made uh
over a hundred thousand dollars on only
fans how did that feel great really
great
I mean like uh
well actually because so much you're
upbringing you didn't have money it's a
struggle with the factory job and so on
um maybe a good person to ask can uh
money by happiness
uh well I mean I think you get like a
resting set point of Happiness
regardless of how much money you have
but money can buy being less stressed I
would say
is there a lot of variation in the um
in the basic rest happiness for humans
in general like is that is that a good
thing to think about I mean they've done
some studies but again like again I'm
not sure I haven't actually read the
study so maybe they didn't replicate
where like they measured people before
and after winning a bunch of money to
see if their happiness is higher yeah I
think like it's by some measures it
wasn't by some it wasn't no I mean like
basically almost genetically so nature
nurture but
is there let's say after you're 18 is
there like some stable
level of happiness
that all the environmental genetic
factors combine to create so that
everything that life throws at you
uh has to face that happiness I think
you mentioned earlier that I seem to be
happy with a lot of stuff so maybe I
have a certain level do other people
have a lower level some people have
higher level yeah definitely like is
there is that a useful or
is that a useful model of human beings
or is it all ups and downs
like is it all like I mean there's no
combo right like I don't know some
people just are happier than others in
general and other people aren't but then
you also have ups and downs like I'm
sure you've experienced sadness
sometimes and happiness the other times
like if I actually were to integrate so
to have an integral under the area under
the onto the Curve
I don't know if I'm different than other
people maybe I'm just like really
focused on the happy moments and maybe
feel the down moments most intensely and
maybe that like
on average it's all the same is that
possible I mean maybe
I just I don't know like I remember when
I was a kid my mom would call me
Pollyanna all the time it's always like
finding the good and everything yeah I
mean like something bad would happen you
were a happy kid I was really happy kid
yeah even in uh in the harsh conditions
yeah I mean like I said like I think the
harshness comes from the bad meaning
like and I had good meaning applied to
it you were a stoic yeah with another
book I'm reading next week tune in
Marcus Aurelius meditations
all right all right uh camming 100K so
it felt good so
it's crazy though right you can just
like
take clothes off in a creative way with
some gnomes and make a hundred thousand
yeah I mean there's a lot more to it
than that but yeah what was it what's
what's the difference marketing like so
with with only with my free cams I was
unusual and that I decided to do outside
of the website marketing I like post on
Reddit right this was very unusual at
the time but like only fans are
structured such that uh they have almost
no internal Discovery whatsoever so if
you want people to come to your page you
have to go out on the external websites
and advertise for yourself directly very
different model and so this is something
that I had already been doing and
already had practicing and so I think I
was like already quite Advanced like I
already had an account on Reddit that
was like seven years old at the time
tons of like Karma that means I could
post in subreddits I already been on
Twitter for years you know like posting
actively so I I already had like
presences on all these other platforms
that really helped with the conversion
Reddit and Twitter Reddit Twitter
FetLife Instagram Tick Tock and you are
still advertising creatively so like
there's like sexuality but there's also
like creative sexuality yeah and ideas
too yeah like one of the really popular
ones was I like molested myself as a as
a mime using a uh a one arm through a
jacket and so the jacket looked like it
was
uh the jacket looked like it was alive
and
you know and that one did really well
did you like brainstorm with somebody
and like I recently got to hang out with
Mr Beason I said uh uh on a session of
brainstorming different ideas
I just envisioned you with like a team
brainstorming all right how about we try
the mime and the molesting thing I don't
know it's too too edgy
I wish I think the tea would were fun
but no it's just me like I had an
apartment that looked like kind of like
this you know you just sit alone you're
like well that would be a good idea and
I'd seen you should collect ideas over
time right like
um I'd seen somebody doing a version of
the like this this animated hand act
like when I was a kid and I just always
stuck in my head and like one day I was
like I bet I could do that and then I
was thinking trying to think of ideas to
do as a sex worker I was like why don't
I just try that and then it turned out
to be like like a really like quite a
viral hit is there um is there stuff
like you mentioned to edgy like Mr Beast
tries to keep it PG yeah do you try to
keep it PG-13 well with the sex
advertising stuff I mean it's sex
advertising so it's obviously not PG-13
I don't know these ratings what is even
beyond that family friendly it is X like
even though the one that I'm describing
to you at some point like you can see my
boob so there's a boom is is ex my boob
is I guess it's not hard I think you can
show a boom in bg30 yeah maybe X is like
if you got some sort of rhythmic motion
going on
maybe that sound but the rhythmic was
actually not
you could have one or the other but you
can't have both they have both that's
when we hit the X
so definitely not family I mean with the
sex advertising stuff like guys like
vanilla [__] guys want basic hot girl
you can do something like kind of sexy
and creative like getting abducted by
gnomes or like the self molestation
right but those are still pretty within
the normal boundaries
what do you mean guys like vanilla stuff
I mean most guys like vanilla stuff
what's Vanilla stuff like see how talk
about fetish
fetishes I think my uh Overton window on
what is vanilla is expanding
quickly after following your work but
yeah I actually have done a lot of
studies on what is vanilla like I've
done a couple different surveys where I
ask people like how taboo is this thing
and I have like a rating from least to
miss taboo by the way I don't like I
don't appreciate the beauty of vanilla
ice cream you don't it is really good
though
you eat vanilla ice cream I eat vanilla
ice cream yeah I think there's just so
many more options it's like the absence
of creativity I mean if you put in like
some chocolate chips or something
now they already made it more
interesting
um to start okay so what's Vanilla what
and why do guys like vanilla so hot girl
doing hot girl things what like
undressing and then yeah sex the thing
that I found was most successful were
frames where the man was framed as
passive and the woman is active or like
for example uh like oh you know we got
assigned to the same bunk uh at the
breeding school or something or like oh
we're the last people on earth right or
like oh no uh you know I like I
desperately need somebody to like cure
me with this disease and I need semen so
it's like in any scenario where the guys
just like finds himself such that the
woman like desperately needs him for
some reason and he doesn't have to do
much that is like typically one of the
much more successful things like guys
like women falling into their lap what
about the power Dynamic
um so guys are less into power dynamics
than women are and you can do power
dynamics as long as it's like handed to
them some guys obviously some guys are
like very dominant like prefer like
having to work but this is the minority
like if you're trying to do make 100K in
a month and you're trying to appeal the
whitest group of people the most
effective advertising you're not gonna
be making the most money by being like
particularly submissive so on the
camping side that's your uh unlike a
like uh escorting or just personal
relationships you're trying to you have
an audience
you have like a theater full of people
like with live camming yeah with live
camera yeah it's like a live theater is
that freak you out there's just a bunch
of people watching I mean what how do
you feel right now I don't I don't know
their watch because it's not live yeah
that's true it's not live so like it
might as well be like they could be
watching
I feel like there's just the two of us I
don't know and there's like I feel
sometimes I imagine there's a third
person like God usually no no not not
God just I usually imagine
um
either a guy or girl or a couple just
sitting there for some reason like
usually on the beach and usually high or
on some kind of like about mushrooms
just like listening passively just kind
of looking at the sunset that's what I
imagine well that's really good yeah I
think it's useful like when I write my
blog posts sometimes I do terribly but
it's the most effective when I imagine
one person that I'm writing to to try to
explain and like having a high couple
watching the sunset is maybe really
lovely as a calibration I have to say it
is pretty romantic
because I've gotten a chance to meet
couples that listen to podcasts together
I don't know why that seems like
intensely romantic to me because like
because you're not watching TV together
you're listening to a thing I mean I
guess sometimes they watch it but like
you're listening to ideas together
I don't know see it seems like you're
going through the same kind of thought
process yeah yeah that's a really
beautiful way to put it so it's like
you're melding your thinking is
following the same life some of my
podcasts do that more than movies I
think movies give you a lot more freedom
to think about stuff I feel like your
thoughts are aligned and like especially
if the if the podcast is good like if
it's listening to
um like a Dan Carlin podcast about
history that you're like on a journey
together
ah is there's an intimacy to that anyway
um but I I've learned that those couples
do that
you know hashtag relationship goals go
ahead that's what you want with your
future wife with my yeah you should make
an application
application an application for dating
you I mean maybe this is more of like my
strategy and less yours but you have
like a wide enough audience that might
work
I it's not
um
okay let's just go there so because you
put together an application of like
people to have casual sex with you I
think and also dating yeah and also
dating in relationship I'd love to so
what is in that application because like
you know
um
I'm sure there's a quite a lot of people
that would like to date you or to sleep
with you but finding the person I mean
it depends what your goals I guess
relationship would be an open
relationship for you yes right like for
me I guess it's more intensely selective
because it's like a monogamous
relationship and a committed one like
like like I'm I'm swinging for the
yeah like for like long term I'm not I'm
not like weirdly obsessed with long term
but it's like you just I would love to
have one girl for the rest of my life
but
finding that I feel like applications
will not get to that I feel like there's
some aspect of the magic of the the
Serendipity of it of meeting people in
strange places and so on I just I
personally have noticed that like Fame
has not made that process easier but I
mean like if you could you know if
there's two rooms and one of them it's
like a random population of hot women
and the other one is very unpopulation
of hot women but all of them definitely
are monogamous and are looking for a
long-term relationship yeah like which
room would you rather go into
like if you're looking for a mate yeah
well but see I guess my preferences are
more this this is a really strong point
but my preferences are represent the
majority probably right because don't
most women want monogamous relationships
yeah so like it's I'm okay with either
option
because like statistically speaking but
I feel like we can apply it to like a
bunch of other things yeah and I'm just
this is just a problem if you have like
high if you have a high volume to filter
through and you're like you don't know
like it's a good like initial filter
like you can take it from like a
thousand people to 20 people and then go
to dates with them but the filter is so
anti-romantic like what
this is true this is not the Romantic
narrative that uh that you're very proud
I feel like how did you two meet well
she passed the three filters I set up
and uh
I mean but that's also but also can you
put into a survey the things that you're
interested in
yeah I mean I definitely think about
this a lot with hiring like like the
teams engineers and so on
but with engineers
you're okay losing truly special
Engineers because you have to filter
because there's like thousands of
applications like it feels like
it feels like I worry that you would
miss the thing that actually
because so much of his chemistry so much
of it it's like the magic you know the
thing is you're missing it anyway like
yeah you're missing it oh you can just
run it and then in addition try some of
those people
and then go on the dates that you're
going to go on with anyway regardless
it's just the thing that helps like pull
someone out of the crowd like this I I
dated a guy from my survey I'd ran the
survey I assigned Point values to the
questions yeah I went on a date with
like the top couple people and then one
of them I was like
and I'm still dating him to this day it
was awesome
and I would never I never would have
gone on a date with him without the
survey can you can you if from memory or
we can look it up do you remember what
kind of questions were on the survey I
asked a couple different categories I
asked about like basic life stuff so
like what kind of relationships like
monogamy versus polyamory like do you
want kids you know like where you want
to live like basic things that you need
to be compatible and then I asked like
sexual compatibility like various
preferences and then I had a section
about like personality like what a per I
try to ask questions that would do the
most effective filtering so like what
are ways that like I can't give give
people what they need that like maybe
they really want like I don't really I'm
not very outdoorsy and it's just very
common a lot of people like being
outdoorsy so I asked the question like
how much do you value someone else that
you're dating being outdoorsy have they
marked yes I was like okay we probably I
should probably download man but doesn't
polyamory make that really difficult
because can't they find somebody for the
outdoorsy stuff yeah they could I mean
this doesn't like but if you're going to
have somebody it's like nicer to have
them be more compatible than less but
you're a little bit like in terms of
sexual compatibility you're able to
like you're self-aware enough to know
what preferences you have like you can I
think so I think that one helped a lot
with the escorting like the escorting
helped a lot with knowing my preferences
but there's like out of the the Giant
pool of different preferences you
haven't like a subset that's clearly
defined for you
okay like like dominant submissive yeah
Power Dynamic stuff hard to announce
that
okay in the not just sexual blend
relationship too like that was that in a
survey I don't like paradigms in
relationships I'm not defining them in
like making it clear in a survey like
asking a question about power dynamics
in a relationship I don't think I asked
about power dynamics in relationships
okay because I just assume most people
don't and there's a lot of things that
are kind of like most people don't
you're putting together a survey a
systematic server to understand
compatibility
wouldn't power dynamics inside of
relationships that naturally emerge
often be part of the question or or is
that is that hard to question because it
naturally emerges the thing is like a
lot of questions sort of overlap in
demographic and if you're making a
survey you want to have the minimum
possible questions that give the maximum
possible like filtering information so
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute but that purpose of
that survey wasn't to do a good research
study it was to select one subject that
you could take so that's part of what's
is good like you want to most
efficiently filter out because one like
you get more people taking the survey
the fewer questions you have which is
good for finding a mate like if you have
5 000 men take the surveys better than
one thousand medications don't you want
men that that would be patient enough
and dedicated enough yeah but like what
if you're like a high-powered man who's
like on his lunch break yeah right so
it's like you're just like a billionaire
is too busy just flipping through yeah
and the guy that I did was that he took
the survey he was waiting for the piece
to come to come out of the oven and so
it was important that it was short
are literally pizza coming he's
literally waiting for pizza and he saw
the things like I guess I'll just fill
up the survey really fast and it changed
our lives so romantic I I it's for me
this is my kind of Romance I'm really
into it but but you could it could be
efficient with surveys by like making
sure your questions don't overlap so for
example if somebody's very polyamorous
they're very unlikely to be interested
in like a traditional like man works and
like and out and the job in the woman
stays home and raises the kids kind of
relationship because probably people
just generally don't do that and so if
I'm asking about polyamory it's sort of
kind of already covers the thing and so
if I have a whole bunch of questions
like I can kind of like triangulate a
bunch of implicit kinds of questions
that I haven't directly asked about
so this is why I didn't ask directly
about power dynamics because like from
the rest of the questions that are in my
survey like I can pretty accurately
predict whether or not you're going to
be interested in power dynamics but I'm
afraid yeah like I'm trying to think as
you're talking I get it it's
that's really interesting that you did
that also maybe not for the
effectiveness of finding a partner but
for just exploring the actual the
process
of of human sexuality of of like the
search this this complicated
optimization process we're all engaging
in on the landscape of happiness that
seems to be uh this
um
not even a differentiable function it's
it's a giant non-linear mess okay but
like for me I don't think I would be
able to design that survey I would like
bias it too strongly like um
I'll probably prefer women
that have read Dostoevsky or something
like that like there'll be a filter for
me right yeah but like that's a horrible
filter because there's a lot of like
there's a lot of amazing people that
have never they don't give a [__] about
reading or they don't give a [__] about
reading Russian literature or they don't
give a [__] about but they're amazing
and passionate and creative and all in
some other dimension that you might
completely Miss but you're like because
I wonder if there's any basically you're
saying compatibility like hard lines
that you know statistically is just
going to be an issue yeah I mean you
wait this a lot more yeah but there's
also like preferences like if you have a
woman who's totally equal and she's read
the thing that you like virtue is
another woman who's also identical but
like she hasn't read the thing that you
like like you probably like very
slightly prefer the one but you don't
know what the identity yes yes but like
you can't through survey get the
identical like you don't know sure but
you can kind of like like do a whole
bunch of weight so like the person that
like I ended up going on a date with he
and did not answer like correctly to a
lot of the survey questions but he
didn't have to like he was just overall
overall the weights were like he just
tended to be more in the direction was
there a text-based fill in like a survey
but like uh sorry a paragraph like no
you want to avoid that if you're dealing
with like large amounts of data no why
not because you have to fill oh oh
interesting interesting like I'm I'm
different because like first of all you
can do keyword searches okay that's all
you do you can do machine learning
models that like like uh first of all
you can do you could do like crude
metrics like the length
that's a good point of how long they've
written right
and it could flag certain things yeah
it's actually pretty easy to like I've
I've looked at like for hiring I've
looked at like thousands of applications
really quickly you can really the the
human brain is really interesting
especially
um
like if you visually highlight certain
information for yourself like keywords
or again with machine learning models
like sentiment you can you can highlight
different parts that will catch your eye
better than not and I I can go through
just a huge number of applications are
you telling me I can use if I learn
machine learning I can
process dating survey applications
better yes no like with textual yeah
like I can like have them write things
in like this is like a new way of that
would be yeah it's a really good
incentive I think that would so it's a
really nice aspect
of text input like long form text input
multiple long form text input based on
an interestingly phrased question is you
get to learn how to make a better survey
I think you would appreciate that like
you start to see how they're actually
interacting with these questions like I
ask certain questions like um just to
see how people think is it better to
work smart or better to work hard
foreign
or
um is it uh ever okay to betray a close
friend
like I'll ask like questions like this
that don't really have a right answer
but I just want to see how they think or
is uh truth more important than loyalty
yeah
and and I get their long-form answer you
get like and you get to see the
reasoning process yeah yeah like what
they it reveals so much not just about
the person but about the kind of
questions I want I should be asking that
has nothing to do with truth or loyalty
but like how to get a good engineer with
like very specific questions but I think
it's really useful to get text input I I
have done text input usually with beta
surveys so I usually do beta service
before I do the real survey what's the
biggest like I do like a shorter version
or it depends on what I'm doing but like
a different version of the survey that I
have people take before I release I use
the information from the initial survey
to inform the questions that I ask in
the real survey and I haven't actually
in recently but I used to do a lot of
like the text-based questions to see for
similar although I don't think I relied
it on it quite as heavily and if I
introduce machine learning things would
be a lot more efficient I love that
you're also doing like you're writing
scripts and stuff like you're doing
you're doing something like uh like
statistical analysis are using python
also yeah I had to Learn Python for
and the best reason to learn machine
learning is to solve actual like
problems I can't be motivated I'm just
not motivated to learn something unless
there's an actual curiosity I have and I
have to learn it to solve it I was
trying to avoid learning coding for so
long but eventually it was my data set
became too large I couldn't work with it
with anything else so
oh python it is you know what's also an
interesting data set that you're
probably interested in a little bit is
like Twitter itself right I don't know
if you've I've played with the Twitter
API a lot can you just get
the download the I'm just I'm stuttering
now because the Twitter you download
Twitter
no there's a lot of Twitter Twitter so
Twitter is a social network with a bunch
of people that are interacting a lot
like there's like I don't know the
number's insane the number of
interactions but there's different
ways to interact to get data from
Twitter there's streams you can look at
it depends what you're interested in you
can do uh results for searches you can
look at individual tweets and get entire
which to me is super interesting the
entire tree of different conversations
or the replies which might be very
interesting for you because like
it's not
I it's it's much harder to ask rigorous
questions which you do with your polls
but you could see like how divisive
certain things are yeah like calibrators
to figure out like exactly what
questions you should be asking yeah and
also highlight interesting anecdotal
things when like two people freak out at
each other and just argue like a thread
that goes on for like a thousand
messages that you might never be even
aware is happening because you're like
because Twitter doesn't like surface
that like it would be Twitter doesn't
make it easy for you to like visualize
what the hell's going on even with your
social network like uh like if you post
something that's controversial that gets
a large amount of attention it you can't
clearly visualize everything that's
going on yeah like it's it's very
it's a blurry amorphous like you're just
kind of looking through the fog at
different replies and the kind of it's
uh yeah so the API they have like like
graphs of networks they have the data
for the graphs yeah so you can
reconstruct yourself yeah and then you
have different levels of access in terms
of how many queries you can do
that's really cool and now because
there's like uh Elon
um there's a lot of sort of
revolutionary stuff happening at Twitter
I think
you could literally sort of push for
Innovation there like there's aggressive
Innovation happening so in terms of uh
requesting stuff for the API you could
do all that kind of stuff I think
Twitter is just a fascinating platform
for the as cliche as it sounds for
studying
for me it's interesting what makes for a
healthy conversation that term has been
used but it's interesting how
conversation to me is fascinating how
conversations break down
and not like how like the virality of
drama
or conflict or disagreement how that
evolves when a large number of people
are involved when a large number of this
no no
um misinterpretation of of statements is
involved in text-based with some
anonymity thrown in like I feel like
there's a lot of studies that can be
done there I mean Twitter's probably not
great at it right as it stands no
because it's like necessarily short you
can quote trait things out of context
Etc but but we should understand that
right at a scale at a large scale you
should be able to uh study that kind of
thing oh yeah what was your casual sex
uh survey actually haven't looked at in
a while I think I just asked people
about a whole bunch of fetishes because
you don't want to be obvious about yours
because when people are going to hijack
it to try to tell you that they like
what you like so you want to be obscure
so how do you design a survey where
you're testing for a thing but you're
still obscure about the thing you're
trying to ask about so you still see it
as a survey
yeah yeah like an application
because you I think you tweet is saying
like I'm thinking of just like showing
up to San Francisco and saying
is anybody open for casual sex stuff
like this am I misremember maybe
escorting I'm not sure oh for escrow
sorry which is similar like I kind of
use escorting as the way to have casual
sex now
okay so let's talk about escorting so
you uh wrote about escorting your blog
post escorning was good for me
um
how did you get into escorting I was
working at like a I'd quit camming
because I was burned out and I was like
trying to work at a friend's startup and
it was
hard for me I don't it's difficult for
me to work on projects that are not my
projects
uh
and so I was like hey [__] it like I
want to go back to sex work I want to
make more money but I don't want to cam
anymore because I'm burned out so I'm
like well let's try I have a friend
who's an escort I'm like let's try that
and so we had a call she'd like outlined
the basics for me and then I just put up
some ads and started working what's the
basics of us corny how's that work the
base if you want to get started
escorting so just yeah
uh are you gonna wanted to get some nice
photos so you probably won't have those
first of all you you assumed I haven't
done it before have you yeah well you
know uh Recreation I would like to do
professionally I suppose so if I wanted
to do it
if I wanted to do it if I really really
want to step up my game how would I do
it
yeah well you got the whole tutorial
recreational
I just
okay okay no meaning like like
you know like selling products on Etsy
versus
doing a startup
yeah uh well I mean escort is kind of
also selling products on Etsy you know
like but selling a lot of products high
volume
yeah like like yeah small handcrafted
it's a small Artisan Dolls yeah
this is mass manufacturer
okay on a mass manufacturer your escrow
I just feel like I haven't been getting
you know I've been undervaluating my
services and I would like to really step
up I think you could really just like
grease some marketing gears and
be true yeah I mean it's just some of
this is marketing so like how I guess I
want to like know is it similar to
camming in that way like is it um you're
basically advertising yourself and
you're
uh like the marketing the all the
creativity that you mentioned before all
of that yeah I found a it's going to be
pretty easy because escorting is not
like highly competitive for example
camming is highly competitive because
like the Strat the thing that I outlined
before you know the amount of money that
you make determines your ranking and you
can also go and see other girls you can
see what they're doing so if a girl
figures an incredible strategy for
making money it's like two seconds
before that strategy per little threats
into everybody else so it's very fast
paced and like really tough with
escorting you don't get to see what
other girls are doing you can look at
their websites but like you don't know
what they're doing with clients at all
you can look at their rates but you
don't know what their volume is so you
don't actually know what is successful
and what isn't very much
um so I think there's much less uh like
evolution of marketing through the
through this process and so I came in
with like my aggressive marketing skills
for being a cam girl I think that really
helped I did very well as an escort I
just came in like made a fantastic
website and I knew how to do the ads
right
and what was the finding people I guess
is also like finding the right kind of
customer
one of the right kind of client I got
like in a lot of trouble for this
recently in the sex workers sphere
because I said that if you raise prices
you're more likely to encounter clients
that aren't going to abuse you
like it's safer yeah uh they did not
they said that I was being classist you
know implying that poor people are more
violent but to be fair if you're a guy
and you want to be violent towards a
woman you're probably not going to be
paying a lot of money you're probably
gonna be like you're the kind of person
likely who's going to haggle a lot
because you don't respect her yeah but
anyway that aside it's a little pet
peeve for me
um yeah I just I charge started charging
800 an hour and then pretty rapidly
raised it to 1200 and then a while after
that race it to 1400. well the
interesting thing you mentioned in my
extensive research
um you used to do 1200 to 1400 an hour
and then you said that you're thinking
of jumping back in at a rate of 2400
the first hour yeah and I think 900 each
successful hour that's interesting
that's like that's that I mean to me
that's really interesting like the for
like why it's like the first hour yeah
oh it's just because uh it depends on
how you want to incentivize like the
amount of hours so if you have to pay a
lot for the first star but not very much
for the success if you're more likely to
buy like a longer period of time and
usually I find that clients who buy a
longer period of time are nicer to you I
don't have like a great theory for why
that is but there's more likely like
taking dinner and get to know you first
and I just enjoy that a lot more I enjoy
like
like knowing who I'm gonna have sex with
like a date you know yeah so it
incentivize the the long form date
Dynamic versus like uh not that's really
interesting
that's so interesting how does money
change the dynamic just basic human
Dynamic of interacting for free versus
for money like I think about that a lot
it's like just talking to rich people
it's like you usually get paid for your
time and you're doing this for free like
what uh
like what's the difference is there a
difference really or no
so when I was doing it full time it was
my only source of income
it changed quite a lot because I was
really incentivized to have repeat
customers so I'm like okay if I'm my
primary interaction with you is to like
have you hire me again I will do
whatever that takes to make that happen
and so if I have to like laugh at jokes
that I find funny or like to be like
more adoring of your penis than I
actually genuinely feel like that's what
I'm going to express yeah um and
obviously it's to some degree like
titrated you know like I it's unpleasant
to force yourself to like something that
you don't so like I would actually like
not see clients again that I didn't want
to but it's just some degree there was a
sort of self-suppression going on which
I think is this the way it works in any
sort of customer service job like you
want the customer to leave happy so you
just make sure that you are happy the
whole time and you're like ah really
enjoying the other person but uh so
recently when I've like kind of dabbled
in it since baking money for through
other means
um where I don't need the money it's
more like a fun side thing that like it
that I'm like I said it's fulfilling the
role of casual sex for me so like I
don't have to do it this is not my
primary job I just want sort of a good
excuse to like have sex with somebody
and the money is like a great filter for
that and so in that case that's
interesting so the money is there but
yeah okay the money is basically a
filter for somebody who's taking this
interaction seriously yeah it also so
there's an interesting like
psychological thing where I have
difficulty having casual sex with
somebody because some part of my brain
which I assume is like quite female is
doing some evaluation of status and
whether or not this is going to damage
my reputation by having sex with them so
like if you found out that I went and
like had random sex with like a homeless
man you might be like wow that says
something about Ayla like maybe she's
you know trashy or she just has no
standards for who she's gonna [__] but
if and so some part of me is continually
anxious I'm like does this mean I have
no standards if I decide to have casual
sex with you like what are people going
to think uh and so if you introduce
money it takes away that anxiety I don't
have to worry about it because it's like
oh of course Ayla would have sex with
that person they paid her like this is
not an indication of the kind of mate
that she can get this is just an
indication of like a business
transaction and this allows me to enjoy
casual sex so much more when somebody
pays me for it to the degree that like I
almost view it as Kink and so it's like
so I'm using it sort of to replace
casual sex now like occasionally I'm
like you know like pay me a little bit
to erase the anxiety and I'll like have
a fun fun time in case you see like
dinner like that or something like that
if the person pays for dinner or like so
like it's all just if any money's
involved if it's a kink then you could
just like use it and you
you buys a coffee at a Starbucks it's
like all right great but it has to be
plausible like you have to like trick my
brain into like having it actually be
incentivizing for me
like China or something yeah like the
homeless man bought me a coffee and then
I sucked this dick like that's not cool
all right so no shade of homeless man by
the way like I've been friends with a
lot of them I'm just using like some
sort of stereotype of yeah right now so
like it has to be plausible where you
could trick your mind interesting yeah I
mean yeah
and so that's different so now now with
in this sort of frame I am still like
I'm accepting money but still much more
expressive of my actual preferences so
like I before when I would start
escorting full-time I was suppressive
and now I'm like you know like I'm doing
this for me so we're going to make sure
that I have a good time and so I'm much
more demanding
and then you're having more fun because
you're not pretending exactly laughing
at a joke or something like that that
sounds terrible
sounds like I mean it's also like social
I mean I guess I I would
would I do that like when you first meet
people like strangers and so on there's
some aspect of like
niceties but like I don't know intimacy
like real intimacy requires like getting
past the nice cities like laughing at
somebody's joke when it's not funny
feels like anti-intimacy yeah
how many jokes automatically if
interesting because like I don't mean to
I'm not trying to be fake but like if
I'm in a group of people and somebody
makes a joke and everybody laughs I
laugh even before I'm checking within
myself like do I genuinely enjoy this
joke yeah so it's like I don't know like
the degree that I am sort of just like a
result of social programming in all
cases that like when I'm with a client
back when I was doing it full time like
it doesn't feel significantly different
it just felt like a different version of
myself
yeah that's true yeah to that degree to
the degree you don't feel like you're
going against yeah your your nature yeah
yeah it was very rare that I actually
felt like I was
against my nature
um what about the market of how much to
charge
say 20 2400 like how transparent is that
market is there like a market like how
much can you sell when you're charging
that much yeah no like what what are the
competitors like if this oh yeah like
what do are you distinctly what because
you said it's uh a lot of is a is a bit
more shrouded a mystery I guess a more
confidential like do you have some
transparency to the the market what the
competitors are so a survey of escorts
only like 130 I'm trying to remember and
the median was around like 400 300 I
think an hour oh wow something like that
with a very long tail at the top end if
I'm trying to remember what the I also
asked the amount that I could calculate
the amount they made per month I think
it was like six or seven thousand
dollars a month I need to double check
that one but I charge 50 bucks an hour
you charge 50 bucks an hour you should
raise your rates yeah I believe I give a
really shitty hand job
um all right but usually the the rates
are around like if you want a median
escort in a big city it's usually four
days a city so the urban sorry four four
to six hundred I'm in a big city but
like smaller cities you charge the rates
go lower
um
so that's so fascinating what's like the
most you've ever seen somebody charge
uh
um I I think I am you're like the
but at this point it's because I'm post
work like I can I can just put it in the
same number there's like in like does
the fact that you're sort of
like a sexuality expert like uh
researcher and so on like your mind is
fascinating as well and you're a bit of
a celebrity there's that play into it
yeah uh do you feel the celebrity no
like yeah with people yeah absolutely
usually if people are interested in
hanging out with me it's because of that
um
but that's that's different like I think
besides the like the the fun part like
the this is a kink as opposed to this is
a job like with this as a job usually
the high end is closer to two thousand
an hour like the very high end have
clients ever fallen in love with you
I think so yeah I think it doesn't
happens to me much less than most other
people due to like the thing I think we
were talking about before which is what
we're like you know you give off five
maybe like subconscious Vibes but they
have fallen in love or not but not as
often I think I something about my
signaling indicates that people should
not fall in love with me because I don't
think it happens very much and it
happens a lot with other women that I
know but I have occasionally had the
thing is it's it's hard for me because I
try to be as vulnerable as I can in a
connection with a client
um I like I do really like some of them
I I still remember some of them very
fondly and I'm like I hope they're doing
well and some of them are really
profound like one guy saw me because he
found out he was dying of cancer and he
was like I don't want to die without
seeing someone I'm like Jesus Christ
that's such a
I don't know I'm very touched by many of
the people that I saw so there's like
deep intimacy there yeah it's I know
that it's brief and I know that it's
like kind of weird but like there's
there's like a real glimpse into
somebody's Soul when you get to be
intimate and I think this is especially
if you're for men because a lot of time
men don't have like a way to be really
vulnerable in front of anybody but like
if you're in bed with a woman that you
find to be attractive you can
sort of let loose a little bit more so
they can become vulnerable in general
quickly yeah and I really like that I
like you being as vulnerable as I can to
match it like I'm not forcing myself or
anything but like I just feel into it
and like notice how like beautiful the
person was and like feel grateful for
being able to be in this intimate
experience with them
and that was so wonderful
does it ever hurt to say goodbye
uh no but I think that's as unique to me
because I like being alone a lot even
with my friends who are like dearly I'm
like happy not seeing them
uh because I don't like making facial
expressions very much but I do miss some
of my clients wait sorry what does make
a facial expression have to do with
saying goodbye well if if you are not
with somebody in person you don't have
to make facial expressions anymore
oh you can just think about them yeah
you can just you can just sit there
totally blank face and then have all of
the emotions that you want are you
telling me do you have this thing too
it's not a thing but like you're on
camera yeah so like I feel feelings but
people usually want you like social
interaction is such that like you
probably want me to show feelings on my
face yeah like that good job yeah hey
there you go so like I I I definitely
that there could be just an introvert
thing where you like have an vibrant
inner world
that you forget to show to the rest of
the world and also I'm scared of social
interaction and I just have a lot of
anxiety about interacting with the
external world so yeah I'm kind of
surprised to hear that because
because when you talked about like
finding the light and everything and
everything is fun like I usually don't
associate that with having not very much
anxiety well because I have the we
mentioned that earlier I just appreciate
the beauty in the world when I observe
it but then when I'm interacting with
others
I have a very harsh self-critical aspect
to my brain that says like
you're gonna [__] this up you're gonna
[__] up this interaction you're going to
[__] up the the beauty that's there if
I'm sort of being oh fragile and
vulnerable for a moment one of the
things I'm afraid of that gets so much
love from from people that listen or
even like reach out like you said
through the survey like women and so on
I'm afraid that yeah you know you admire
me because you don't know me but you
won't admire me once you know me so that
that's self-critical but it's a silly I
mean as you get older you're like yeah
okay like I'm able to step away and
objectively look at myself I was like
there's no this is you're fine you're
good like but it's still there this is
the part of the brain that you can't
just shut off does it is like what would
[__] up in this conversation look
like
like it doesn't have to be rational but
I'm curious if there's like a specific
thing
a lot of it is just a feeling like an
amorphous fear
of failure
what it would actually look like
maybe because we're talking about
sexuality me not being able to
eloquently explain
the world view I have and why I
appreciate
appreciate it
that would make me feel like a failure
because that would make me feel like
maybe you don't know what you're doing
right because sex sexuality and not
sexuality which is even romantic
relationships are really important to
happiness to they're really important to
me and I'm not sure like the conception
of love I have romantic love
is like fully um
made rigorous so especially when I'm
talking to you that thinks very
rigorously about a lot of these topics
I'm not sure if I've thought about them
a lot I feel them I interact with the
world in this base of feelings
maybe I'm almost afraid to be very
rigorous with these kinds of thoughts
and so I think
the the failure would be like I would be
confronted with the fact that I can't
explain
what makes me happy that could be a
failure and there could be just a bunch
of other failures another big failure is
like uh not I think you're a really
brilliant person
um and a lot of folks I know know and
admire your work as well and so like for
me not to
be part of highlighting that Brilliance
would be a failure definitely
like because then other people might
feel like like notice the discrepancy or
something yeah no no no that's not other
people just my personal life my personal
feeling and like the other is like jokes
because like we're talking about sex
right so for me like it's fun to just
joke around but you also have to tread
carefully because like
it's it's a weird it's a weird surface
because like you know even I already
feel bad about making a joke for 50
bucks for a hand job that's crappy by me
um but I think
I think sometimes you just gotta go for
it I went for it it kind of flat fell
flat on his face but uh
um that's that's the thing with the
conversation I think there's like the
sphere it's like uh if you become like
scientific about something you'll figure
out that your feelings are unjustified
and then you'll experience this horrible
thing where like ah [__] like I'm like
afraid of this but I'm sort of being
forced to by my logical mind to like
believe this thing uh which I don't
think I don't think this is true at all
like I think like your feelings are
there for a reason like they're for a
good reason and like logic or like
rigorous analysis or something should be
dedicated to figuring out why it's there
yeah not that not by not to like
suppress it or tell it it shouldn't be
there you know what do you think is more
important to like
to just life to reason versus emotion
like not life to what makes us human I
guess
my my romantic narrative answer to this
which is like not rigorous at all is
curiosity
curiosity yeah
was is curiosity that's such a middle
curiosity is like both emotion and
reason yeah right so it's like this pull
because reason is the tool you use to
figure out the puzzle and then curiosity
is the pull towards the puzzle yeah I I
don't like the World Series that pit
like emotion and rationality is opposite
each other they feel like beautiful
parts of like a cohesive whole yeah like
if you're doing rationality to the
extent where you're like suppressing
some emotional reactions you have then I
think you're doing it wrong you're like
missing a big part of it like it should
be like integrated it should be like
part of like one unified flow like the
things that you like if you want to be
in a romantic committed relationship for
the rest of your life then this is like
beautiful and good and the kind of like
logic that you're using to make sense of
the world should be fitted into that
correctly I think it's really cool like
anytime you have sort of like an
internal at odds thing with it I think
you're like using some sort of force to
suppress one or the other like I'm not
allowed to reason about this or I'm not
allowed to feel about that and it feels
harsh to me and I think curiosity is the
solution like if you if you're simply
just calmly curious oh why do I feel
like that let's let's go find out that's
so cool right like you can use logic and
your feelings to like discover the
answer
do you sometimes because you do this
kind of technique which is interesting
and I've mentioned it to others you'll
sometimes step away from like a third
person perspective and describe the
feeling you're feeling
or like even just the situation like
you'll step out
and talk about wait what is happening
here like in the conversation in the
conversation itself yeah uh first off
what is that was that do you find that
to be useful and interesting because
it's it's very interesting it feels raw
and honest the danger of it seems like
you escape
the actual experience of it though
so that's the trade-off
you make it intellectual right
though intellectual to do that
I mean maybe it is I don't mean to
no maybe this wrong word
you can make it intellectual yeah but
you can still continue the same flavor
because you're not fully disengaging
from the conversation
you're doing you're just creating an
extra metal layer yeah that's happening
exploring the emotional reaction to
what's going on in the moment yeah yeah
in some way it's actually making a
stronger like or enriching it like
making it more
uh yeah giving him more context giving a
deeper understanding I think there's
like a way of going meta that is is a
Flinch move like oh I noticed that we're
doing this thing I'm going to name it
and I think the thing that I described
earlier like when the homeless guy
approached me and asked you know can you
go home with me and I was like are you
trying to have sex with me right now
like what I was doing is like a meta
like you're stepping outside like and
like okay what is the purpose of this
conversation we explicitly identify it
and in that case I think that is sort of
like a Flinch move like I'm not telling
him my emotional response I'm not like
being fully present I'm like sort of
identifying it as a way to subvert
what's going on and so I absolutely
think this is a possible thing uh but I
usually try to be aware of that myself
it depends on the purpose of what's
going on that guy because that is
actually like a chess move you did you
had a purpose with that chest move but
the flirtation is on
like he could have
like uh done a better move
that would make you like Curious like
yeah that's true like interesting
because you had an agenda with that but
he could have changed your mind like he
he could have with a few words because
you just created extra layers extra
entry points if he had gotten more meta
yeah it might have been like okay well
no I'm gonna
exactly I mean see there is there is
something uh yeah that's AIDS into the
chemistry of the conversation when you
do that matter I really enjoy it it's
like a rare I forget did you not I
forget who I've had a few people do that
with me like just in conversation and I
feel like you were involved somehow
because I've met you before uh somewhere
I don't know if we were or you were just
doing parties together or maybe it was
just like a bunch of people that kind of
play with the same or like this circling
it's just a practice explicitly
dedicated towards that what circling
circling that might be the thing yeah I
think I think so we know we have some
mutual circulars in our circles and our
networks here what's uh what's circling
I don't remember what I'm gonna describe
it horribly because it's like one of
those things that's difficult to
describe unless you experience it like
kind of like drugs yeah but it's
something like you sit around there's
like kind of guidelines to the
conversation where you talk about the
present moment yeah you're like honest
about your experiences as much as you
can be and if you don't want to be
honest then you say I don't want to be
honest
um and your like commitment to
connection so like you're here to
actually connect with the other person
understand them and be understood yeah
um you're not supposed to like project
so if you're like have an analysis about
the other person you own it you're like
I'm experiencing you as this you know
and then you check is it true
um or like are you are you supposed to
be almost like converting it towards the
thing you're thinking like constantly
um if it feels right in the moment you
can the thing is it's very amorphous
right it's like almost like creating a
magical sensation and I've been with
some I've seen some very good circulars
really high skill Circle and I feel like
I'm on drugs when that happens it's very
rare to see
does it feel honest somehow yeah very
honest
like like right now in this moment I'm
feeling like kind of like nervous energy
because I'm talking to you and this is a
unique situation and like I want you to
think I'm cool yeah I want everybody
listed me to think I'm cool but I'm also
having some sort of delight at being
able to express in this way and like
some admiration for how you like set up
and built this thing that I can be a
part of and all of these things are sort
of in my body right now is this sort of
vibrating High thing I remember like in
the party setting because I've got to
talk to a few people I felt like it was
going sexual very quickly
okay I don't know if you remember this
but the first time I met you I didn't
know who you were I just heard I knew
I'd heard your name like here's your
name and like I think I've heard people
discuss that sure and I was in the
middle of a very sexual conversation
with another woman oh you were yeah I
was and you just like turned around and
left very shortly afterwards and I
thought it was right oh was I listening
in on the conversation or something it
was like it was like I was talking to
her and you were just kind of like right
there and so we introduced ourselves and
then we continued on with the
conversation and you were like standing
there and listening yeah and then I
don't think I would have left the cut so
it's funny you probably interpret it in
a different way
as you like not wanting to listen to
like graphic sexual stuff was it like
super graphic I don't know I was I was
asking her about I was doing I was
interviewing her about her fetish
basically oh yeah I don't think I would
have walked away from that I would have
been like Curious oh interesting because
I don't often see people having a deep
interview about fetishes like I wouldn't
even be listen I'm like Jane Goodall
here like I'm not like
I'm not afraid of sexuality or something
like that I just have certain values in
terms of like monogamy and so on but I
think okay sexuality is really beautiful
yeah I I don't think
yeah I can't imagine myself walking away
from that conversation he was somebody
must have like called you or something
because I didn't remember exactly how it
worked I just remember thinking later on
or maybe I thought I was intruding oh
maybe because if I was kind of drunk so
you know I probably was very okay
I would like to actually have like
footage of that conversation so we can
actually interpret what actually
happened because it's probably I mean
you know the human interactions are are
funny like that they could
they can help for all kinds of reasons
um have you ever fallen in love with a
client no I mean like in tiny ways like
micro loves
like have you ever fallen in love love
I mean I don't know what it means but
probably the thing that other people say
when they say fall in love is probably
something I've experienced
what do you think they mean
um
what is love I love yeah I know no it's
a fantastic question I think so love is
one of those words that refers to like a
billion different concepts and I think
we maybe should just tether the term to
have a better understanding what we're
referring to because there's things like
I feel like intense attachment there's
something feeling like like soulfully
aligned there's like sexual attraction
there's like are you excitement talking
to me and saying we should taboo the
term love maybe in this conversation how
dare you no uh
okay
romantic love okay to make it flourish
into lots of other new definitions okay
thank you very much it sounds like
you're censoring the most important word
this is like 1984 all over again
okay but also on the book a reading list
oh okay listen uh no romantic love like
a deep intimacy for somebody else like
it like a deep connection with a human
being that is also I mean yeah with
polyamory It's Tricky and your
relationship with sex is also sex is
also tricky so like what's the
difference between a deep friendship
and that and a friendship that also has
a sexual component I remember being very
confused about that when I did a lot of
LSD I was like what uh the the line
between romantic relationships and
everything else kind of got blurred I
was like oh I'm just like in intimacy
and some intimacies mean that you spend
your life together more and have sex but
like
and the the same basic thing is there
like you're seeing someone for like who
they are
do you think you can be if you're
heterosexual do you think it could be
really deeply close with friends with a
guy and not have sexual relationships
with him I assume it's possible like if
anything is ever possible then probably
yeah
like everything is possible time travel
is possible quantum mechanics makes
every traveling faster than the speed of
light is possible according general
relativity everything's possible so
you're saying there's a chance sometimes
taught me that everything it's probably
impossible not super likely assuming
that they are like attracted to each
other yeah
and for somebody that has surveys and
statistical analysis
we're interested in like what's the
likely thing here versus like what's
possible if you say possible it's like
where anything's open did you just avoid
answering the love thing okay I have a
lot to say about love I just feel like
to be precise yeah okay let's be uh
precisely and precise and continue I'm
sorry that's my phone
uh
it feels like a passive aggressive
suggestion that we shouldn't talk about
love anymore but we shall continue no we
should absolutely talk about love it's
just the term is very confusing because
it's like some people say the word love
and the thing that they're thinking of
is like oh the butterflies like the
sparkle thing that I get in my stomach
when I think about my loved one but I
study relationships over time I just
really like I did a survey about it and
that sparkle goes away within like two
to four years but people still report
loving their partner after that so I'm
like okay like when you say the word
love look what the [__] are we talking
about
yeah it's gonna get on the same page
okay so what are the different so the
butterflies
boy I'd like to push back down two to
four years on the butterflies but okay I
mean statistically not everybody
I butterflies don't give a [__] about
statistics you ever heard of the like
the butter the flap of a butterfly wing
causing like nuclear war
how do you describe that with your
statistics
uh okay so butterflies that's the basic
confession infatuation in the chemistry
of the initial interactions sure but a
deep meaningful connection like
that feels
like sexuality is a component of that
like the kind of intimacy that's only
possible when you're also sexual with
another human being on top of that you
have the butterfly and on top of that
you have the friendship and on top of
that you have like what is that that's a
sandwich the love sandwich the love
sandwich okay I'm down to call it a love
sandwich okay Sam would you call a
sandwich l l us okay what role does that
play in The Human Condition like you've
asked about the Human Condition it's an
interesting phrase yeah I'm not like I'm
like this like not a phrase that's
common in my own thinking
sure Human Condition is a good
summary you know on what do you think
what do you feel when you when I when I
say it's very different kinds of
questions in you
sure yeah which is interesting I've been
trying to like figure out like what kind
of brain like you have is like creating
like this category of question which is
why I was like saying like there's
something about a poetic narrative in
there yeah because it's very like like
like aesthetic I think you've asked much
more aesthetic questions than I do I
don't even know what the word aesthetic
means like artistic artistic yeah well I
mean I know what aesthetic means but I
also don't know what it means it's kind
of like the word love
aesthetic perspective yeah well me but
part of it in conversation you don't
want to ask a question that has an
answer
fully always
do you have an example of a question
that has what's the meaning of oh
does has an answer like one that you was
like oh that's like a bad question
because it has an answer how many sexual
partners you've had in the last year oh
my God
such a okay I feel like we just like got
to some sort of Crux about like the
kinds of questions that we like to
answer sure because I would love that
question okay right to ask enough people
all right but that's does that really
tell the story okay of of what you've
felt over the past year
that's that's true but then I could just
tell you okay so by by when you're
saying the kinds of questions that you
like the ones that don't have an answer
but not an answer you mean like not an
answer where
you can know that you're done telling it
that you can escape having to think by
actually answering it I see
yeah
the struggle
is the place where we discover something
not not the uh not the destination yeah
okay it's working it's working okay so
what is the role of the love sandwich in
The Human Condition okay that's fine I
take I take that question but it's a
stupid question you don't have to it's
I'm ready to do you like do you like
love do you personally look like love
yeah I mean I I think like there's a
part of me that feels like I have
unconditional love for all things like
what you're talking about the class
being beautiful I felt that it's like
that feels like it felt like it rang
something that like I have a a similar
resonance in me for that if I were to
Circle
right now I I feel like you're avoiding
the love question uh-huh the love
sandwich question
what's your own personal feeling towards
loving another human being versus having
sex with another human being
I I think
I love is like one of the concepts that
dissolved for me a long time ago so I
have difficulty directly answering it
sure but I have the experience where you
just describe the love sandwich I feel
like I have had that experience I have
it currently for some people also like
I'm dating people and I have that so
people who you date you you would
describe
sharing a love sandwich with them yeah
okay so how does uh
uh I mean that's great to hear so you're
not Are You Afraid Of Love no not at all
so can you describe to me
polyamory what is it
what does it mean because there's like
different terms yeah you have a nice
blog post about it yeah I have a
personal definition of it which I
readily admit is not shared by a lot of
people but to me the definition of
polyamory is simply not forbidding your
partner from pursuing intimacy with
others yeah it doesn't mean that you
have to pursue it personally like two
people could be married and only have
had sex with each other for 20 years and
as long as they're like you know what if
ever you want to go have sex with
somebody else you're welcome to do that
well the interesting thing you said is
that doesn't mean they have to do it
they just have the freedom to do it yeah
it's the freedom that matters to me
which is uh
uh I mean it's called the the polyamory
post you have so many good blog posts
people people should just go look at
your uh your read your writing because
it's it's really really strong and often
backed by data but also just a deeply
honest look at yourself and your
understanding of the world
it's night it's
yeah it's refreshing to be like with a
lot of stuff I disagree with but I feel
like if I disagree with it you'll be
very open to arguing and and kind of
thinking through it just there's just
the honesty that really is from the
whole thing anyway so uh yes I mean it
would be interesting to kind of explore
what polyamory like how it works what
are the different versions what is the
what does that freedom look like what is
it what does that freedom feel like
to be able to go see other people
depends on you like do you want to go
see other people maybe you do maybe you
don't so usually for me I tend to be
pretty happy with like one or a few
people and then occasionally I like some
novelty so usually I'll go like like I
host orgy sometimes so a whole Synology
and then I'll go have sex with people
with the orgy and then that'll be good
for the novelty for a while ask about
orgies yeah so how many people are in
orgy what's like a standard we're having
a Sunday picnic it's an orgy what's like
a number of people at an orgy I've been
I've only recently started hosting
orgies but I have been to a lot of
orgies and I would say like the median
is maybe 15 people I like how you say
median versus mean okay median is 15
people what's the dish what's the gender
distribution usually uh usually about
even it's like ideal if you can get more
women than men in most of them I've
recently been hosting free use orgies or
or juice where a consent is assumed by
default when you enter and of course you
can revoke it anytime or go over a whole
bunch of rules to make sure it's very
safe wristbands so nobody's actually
doing anything they don't want to but in
those ones you have to have more men
than women I thought free use was like
consensual like at any time
but it's at any time within the
constraints of this building or
something like that you yeah so at the
orgies it's like you buy entering if you
wear a wristband uh then you are like by
default opting into consent so people
don't have to like do a thing where they
negotiate with you and like to be like
is this okay it's just the default is
like you just go for it and if they want
you to stop they say the safer like red
don't and then you have to stop
um and we do like exercise in the
beginning of people saying red to make
sure that everybody knows exactly what
the rules are what's your favorite safe
word red right when I first started
doing like weird kinky [__] I was like
oh let's make a safe word and we pick
the word foliage I was like that's goofy
right and then but then it eventually
came a time where I did actually in fact
want to say the safe word and I couldn't
I was like like in agony I was like
crying like I can't make myself say this
stupid word right now
foliage so after that it's like red
doesn't matter I don't care it's not
funny we're just going with very simple
very practical how does an orgy compare
sexually uh to like one-on-one sexual
experience
um like what is the same ballpark or is
it fundamentally different
I mean the experience of all both orgies
and one-on-one sex could make really
high variety there's a high variety but
you kind of it's a little bit like
you're having sex with someone but
you're surrounded by really realistic VR
porn of other people having sex okay
cool and sometimes there's like three
sums also like maybe there's another
person involved but it's hard to like
have a whole bunch of people on one in
one cluster because usually there's kind
of different little clusters of people
having their experience sure I was part
of a 10 woman orgy it was a total
lesbian thing and that felt like a
writhing cluster it was very nice
but typically you kind of separate out
with like very small PODS of people
doing stuff okay so back to polyamory so
what uh what's a good uh What what does
it take to manage do you have a main
partner if you're being polyamorous and
you have you're dating multiple people
is there usually a main one for you
personally
uh for me personally kind of yes like
right now I kind of two that aren't like
I see roughly around for me it's kind of
just descriptive like if I just happen
to be seeing you a lot more and I've
been confiding you more than you like
you're descriptively my primary partner
but I don't usually have rules to
protect that I'm down with rules to
protect it if you're like you're trying
to build something like I would buy a
house together I'd be like okay we need
to like whatever our relationship is we
have to do the thing we're both paying
the rent for the house or the mortgage
or whatever uh a lot of people do have
primaries so it's very common to have
like X like prescriptive like I'm gonna
get married to you and you're not
allowed to like have anal sex with
anybody else that sort of thing what
about like the transparency and the
communication they have to do yeah you
usually try to be super honest extremely
yeah I mean I've learned over time that
like even if it seems like a very small
thing you talk about the small thing
because often I would just sort of have
like a small Twitch in myself like I
don't know if I like that but I think
okay this is really minor
um it's probably nothing and I don't if
I talk about it's going to make it into
a thing and I just don't want to make it
into a thing you know and I would I've
come to realize that it's worth making
it into a thing because I can't predict
at the 10 time with like the small
feeling I have is going to grow and then
when I grow it now it's like much more
difficult to deal with
so now it's like any little bit of
jealousy I have immediately communicated
I'm like ah I'm a little jealous of you
right now I don't hold that in at all I
used to be kind of like back when I
first started being poly I used to try
to pretend that I was not a jealous
person and that backfired quite a lot
that's really interesting so you do
still feel jealousy oh yeah definitely
and like it and it's also interesting
that you kind of recommend when there's
a little bit of jealousy like to to to
bring that to the surface yeah just like
excessively communicate even if it feels
stupid like this is I feel like a cliche
I feel like a stupid therapist training
video like I just feel ridiculous
sometimes when I'm saying the things but
it's just it's I've learned over time
it's just important to just say the
things because like you know the
traditional view of jealousy is exactly
like you said if you bring it up to the
surface like it's gonna sound like
you're overreacting to everything
but you're saying like still do it
because you're you're basically your
brain blows stuff out of proportion
yeah and it's good to like
a partner like I have partner right now
who's like dating this other girl and he
like really likes her and you like went
traveling with her and stuff and I was
like I feel jealous about it and I have
to tell him that and that way he can be
with me in it he like he like holds me
when I'm feeling jealous and it's like a
bonding experience you know but it's
important for me that like he's able to
handle it like I try not to date people
who really freak out when I have
negative emotions because I want to be
able to express that I'm upset by
something they're doing without it being
taken as a demand that they change their
behavior right I mean he has to be able
to skillfully handle the interaction yes
cool all right you're jealous like I'm
not gonna freak out about I'm not gonna
change my behavior I'm just gonna be
with you in that we're going to sit in
it together
I mean is some of that just insecurity
that you should also just Comfort like
basically alleviate your insecurity
bring it back to like a rational
objective evaluation right my
relationships I love it when people did
not reassure me I like not being
comforted quite a lot okay and so
usually the people I date don't I'm very
gravitating like it's one of the things
people do to make me fall in love with
them is if I say something really like
terrible and they're just like do not
give me any comfort whatsoever but like
that's where my heart gets captured so I
typically am in relationships where I'm
like I mean I'm so jealous and they just
like do not reassure me at all and
that's good because it doesn't give me
an out like I have to deal with it
myself right like that the other woman
is better than me like maybe that is an
actual possible reality which I don't
want to be dealing with my life in a way
where I'm like pretending like I'm only
okay when that reality is not true would
you like them to to uh say that that the
other woman is better than you yeah or
that they if they if they feel that yeah
I mean they should say it in according
to themselves like oh I prefer like I
have a better time with her than I have
with you than I would want to know that
yeah and even though even though that
might be painful to hear yes
that which can be destroyed by the truth
should be
ship what is that that your ego or
something like that my ego so your ego
just generally grows and you like the
destruction of it yeah it's like really
access to the truth it's not it's like a
fun experience like I've
guys be like well you're not as pretty
as I'd like I'm just like oh you know so
stabbed to the heart and but then also
they give me your number after yeah
foreign
what do you think of monogamous
relationships like philosophically can
you maybe steal man or make the case for
monogamous relationships
um can you understand the pros and cons
of a monogamous relationships yeah I
mean depends on how you defend if you're
like hey uh we you can do whatever you
want but you and I are going to spend
the rest like we just you're 80 years
old and like oh we spent 60 years in a
marriage together we've never had sex
with anybody else I think that's like
awesome if that's what you want that's
great
um I have like a little bit more
problems with people doing that while
also forcing their partner not to
misbehave if they want to
like if you're like oh I we only made it
this far in our relationship because I
forced my partner not to pursue an
intimacy that she wanted to then I feel
like a little like more like I don't
know if that's great how do you know if
it's a real want for an intimacy like
checking out a attractive person while
being inside a monogamous relationship
yeah how do you score that that's that
bad that the person cannot pursue those
feelings
uh I mean it depends if they want to
like I often find people attractive I
don't want to pursue
I'm also okay with people entering into
agreements like if you and I want to
agree like I'm only going to enter this
because I'm going to be so hurt if you
pursue somebody else so I'm not going to
pursue anybody else that seems fine to
me but I also extend that like if if
somebody's like I don't want you to have
any friends I'm going to feel really
insecure if you and like okay like if
you want to enter that agreement like I
feel the same way like I think you
should have the right to do it if this
is what you want but I also kind of I
feel like a little weird about
restricting your partner from doing
things you know oh but I guess if you're
honest the bodies put it on the table
yeah I don't want you to have any
friends yeah I want you to sit in a box
yeah I think a lot I guess if you're
like really on the but then if there's
like
there's a power Dynamic that like you
can be quite influential in a
relationship and convincing your partner
and it sure sounds like you're honestly
agreeing to a thing but you're not
really agreeing that's the I mean part
of that is the beauty of relationships
right like
it's messy it can be messy it's hard to
know what you really want right I think
that's mainly my complaint with monogamy
like I'm down with like conscious
monogamy yeah but I think so many
relationships are like monogamous by
default the people sure it's not
actually right for them but they just
get in here because culture just doesn't
give them another option and they don't
even ask themselves the question is this
right for me like which like I'm a
weird-ass person who thinks a lot of
weird [__] but I didn't even think about
my polymers an option before I had heard
that it existed yeah and I was only when
I first met my first polyamorous couple
and I was like oh that's what I am
that's clearly the thing that I am
yeah it's funny because to me monogamy
as is it's not a it doesn't make sense
for it to be a default like to me
monogamy goes against human nature
that's in some sense like romance is a
[__] you to the way the world works
really yeah like it's a like Romeo and
Juliet romance like
traditional description of what romance
looks like versus like sure there's like
a million variations of that but in in
my in my head like this partnership
that's for a long time together is a
kind of you know like uh I don't know
like True Romance you know that movie
it's a really [__] good movie okay
this is just like um
you're together
against the world
yeah that's the
I mean that's what close friendship
feels like it's like ride or die yeah
like that I guess it doesn't it it
doesn't it can be it could span across
multiple you can have multiple partners
in that way yeah absolutely but I just
don't see monogamy as like this
definitely not a default I would
actually like honestly would probably
see polyamory as a more natural default
yeah I mean I guess it depends on what
you mean by default like most of human
history has been sort of a weird mix
like you get polygamy and monogamy or
the kind of the main sure Arrangements
but I think it's just like human nature
like yeah people are attracted to other
people and they want to yeah especially
in longer term relationships I I tracked
and my relationship survey I track the
amount of cheating over time in a
relationship like how long have you been
in this relationship and how have you
cheated
what's what's the results of that men
cheat a lot a lot uh women too but
mentioned about 30 more than women do I
also asked men and women to predict if
they think their partner has cheated and
people's predictions were about the same
so people roughly predicted that they're
male or female like spouse uh hadn't she
about the same rate but mentioned much
more than women so who uh who was more
correct in their prediction though uh so
men were more correct in their
prediction predicting women and women
were that moon or more off women thought
men cheated much less than they actually
did
and but both of them were off but like
the male Gap was significantly more so
yeah I mean you're right when you say
monogamy is not default like I think
you're like really getting at something
like human beings are just especially in
long-term relationships difficult to
only want one person but to be fair I
think manami and commitment are very
different I think you'd be incredibly
I've known so many very long-term super
committed poly couples that live lives
that look very similar to the very
romantic monogamous couples like
children houses like 20 years yeah and
that that works great for them
yeah yeah
I mean there's so much to like open your
mind to in these
kinds of conversation these kinds of
ideas but I also like realize like some
of the cake is baked like I have some
assumptions that are hard to break
through like what for myself like it's
difficult for me to imagine a
polyamorous relationship for me that
would work yeah but I don't have enough
data I don't have a like I have very
little but like at this point
it's like um
I haven't eaten Pizza in like 20 years
because I know I just don't I
disappointing stuff I just eat low carb
because it makes me feel good but
there's so many foods I haven't explored
it's just like well I know what I love
so it was like you probably explore
every once in a while yeah and you kind
of figure that out but at the same time
you're humbled by like even talking to
you or looking at your data like with
sexuality is it is a is a fascinating
topic because it seems that we're very
like we were talking about very afraid
of this topic I like to be really honest
with ourselves about it the the whole
like uh academic research is afraid of
it but it's so core to who we are as
human beings I got to ask you about this
I can't believe it took this long to get
there but one one of your many
fascinating
um surveys is on fetishes
you wrote a blog post about it
uh probably several because it's like a
huge difference still in progress yeah
so uh the one I'm referring to is on
popularity and tabooness
of various fetishes so what are some
interesting takeaways I got to pull up
this graph because it's freaking epic
yes this is a big graph and it has
taboo-ness as one axis and
um popularity as the other
okay for people just listening on the
x-axis is to taboo-ness yeah
asked to rate how taboo Society viewed
the sexual interest and on the y-axis is
percent of people reporting interest log
scale
oh boy all right so just some examples
on the low taboo-ness and high
popularity there's a there's a
correlation here I think you said it's
0.69 yeah it's just not just hilarious
is it still 0.69 are you tracking that I
I haven't that was the motion since I
did this yeah uh so like the last type
of stuff is more likely to be popular
and the more taboo stuff is less likely
to be popular and on the like missionary
position
fingering vagina [__]
light spanking cuddling cuddling is more
taboo than missionary
I think people are conceiving like if
you're like I'm really sexually aroused
by cuddling specifically sure then like
that's a little more weird than getting
specifically arrested by [__] you
expect people to be aroused by blow jobs
so this was like getting at like as a
fetish versus like an activity yes as
specific as like a concrete sexual
interest like I am specifically
interested in this thing yeah and so
those are thighs and lips different body
parts jaw lines and then some of it is
colored based on more female preference
versus uh male preference like Jaw lines
is more
uh female preference
being submissive is more a female
preference light bondage
yeah more female there's a lot of
interesting ones there's so much okay
but then on the The Far Side of that I
mean it gets pretty dark
but even all along the way like extreme
bondage being at 50 tabunus
pegging pain giving pain sexual
frustration I suppose right as a kink uh
yeah
and there's so many interesting ones
like to me like just that I haven't even
like considered
yeah I had to do so much research in the
fetishes to to compile the list okay
sounds surprising like options to you
that you're like oh okay this is like a
fetish yeah well more confusing was like
what the fetishes are about because like
I didn't want to overlap fetish it so I
had to kind of look into them yeah and
I'm like there's like such interesting
manifestations of core drives like if
you're really aroused by disgust like
maybe you're very into rolling around in
dirt but you're not into rolling around
with ice cream so I'm like okay I have
to make those into two separate fetishes
you know yeah and like I'm seeing like a
at the far end
uh
rodents
um
like different types of incest
branding so there's like pain and then
spoon [__] sex with animals I guess
dogs horses
receiving oral sex from an animal is
high tabunas and pretty high popularity
surprisingly High popularity I was
really shocked by that one I wouldn't
triple check that number because I'm
like no way the this amount of people
are reporting interest do you know which
animal is there no I didn't specify I
asked like which animals are robotic and
then I separately asked like how erotic
is it to receive oral sex from your
preferred animal
this is so fascinating so I I would uh
like can we just talk about the
methodology of this
this feels like deeply honest
map of humanity in a way we don't
usually map Humanity yeah
like because it's so many like your
fetishes are so meaningful to each each
individual person yeah that's what I
love about this work it's like nobody
cares about your someone's fetishes you
never get to express them and if you
have a more unusual fetish people
usually judge you so it's like this tiny
little pocket of like this shame thing
but it's so cool to me that like human
brains could be oriented in such a way
like like wound [__] like like
somebody finds that so erotic and that's
so cool
yeah and then they probably and it
should be explored like how did that
come to be you mentioned that we like to
construct narratives that somehow was
grounded in childhood but maybe it's
genetic maybe it has to do with maybe
you can actually form and unform that
fetish very quickly I don't know uh this
is one of the things that I'm
researching so in the big survey that
I'm doing I asked so many questions
about childhood all the ones that I
think like we have common theories about
like oh are you abused it is you yelled
it by a man or a woman
um stuff like that like are you was
really sexually repressive you know is
it gender roles where you've expected to
conform a whole bunch of stuff and then
I asked you know obviously about like a
massive amount of fetishes and my sample
size right now is 500 000 people 500
yeah it's massive and I have stated for
all of it and the result looks like
that's not really correlated nothing
that I asked about in childhood nothing
correlates with fetish preference later
in life it does correlate with onset
lots of things that happen in childhood
can like change like the age at which it
triggers they have so me fascinating
blog post he had a blog post I think on
the age of fetish onset yeah
and uh like you uh you really nicely
organized it by age
like reproduction as a fetish I guess
pregnancy yeah as at age of 17 about
16.9
uh toys and like anal beads is 15.5
yeah one of the interesting things I
found I mean this data set's so huge
it's taking me a long time to go through
it so this is like Snippets from what I
remember when I was glancing through the
data so this part is not rigorous but I
seem to get the impression that um if
you are if a fetish occurs for you
earlier like even much earlier onset
you're more likely to report being
extremely interested into it so later
onset means you're going to be like less
into the fetish but if it hits earlier
but I wonder if it passes like
it's really yeah I didn't measure old
fetishes at all
like no longer right you used to but it
is no longer there interesting one
interesting thing that I don't
understand is that um that uh non-cis
people seem to have more correlation
between childhood experiences and
fetishes so I was saying that there's no
correlation between childhood experience
divisions this holds for CIS people so
trans people specially trans men there's
a correlation it doesn't mean they have
absolutely higher rates of abuse or
fetishes or anything but I'm just saying
that like for them there does actually
seem to be some sort of connection
between childhood experiences and
sexuality later in life and I don't
understand why this applies to one group
but not the other I don't have a good
theory for that so usually you try like
when you see something like that you'll
try to construct Theory and see if you
can find like
you keep that theory in mind like a
hypothesis of why it would be and then
you ask further questions to try to
elaborate
so can you maybe talk about the
methodology of how you got the 500 000
like what
uh like how did this come to be yeah
this is I might go into way too much
detail about this because I thought
about this so much yeah because I'm like
the question is how do you get a lot of
people to take a big survey the longer
survey is the lower the response rate
um and I really wanted to do one big
comprehensive survey so I could like
check a whole bunch of correlations with
it within it uh because it's you know
more annoying and it's harder to get a
lot of people to retake similar surveys
to each other at a time so I'm like okay
I need to convince a very large number
of people to take a lot of these
questions and even building the
questions that was really hard because
I'm like okay I need a comprehensive
amount of fetishes I can't ask everybody
to answer for every single Niche fetish
I'm like do you like ball gags do you
like funnel gags do you like wife shrew
gags or whatever I'm like you can't do
that nobody's gonna do this okay I'm not
good I'm not gonna ask questions what's
the wife true but okay I I'm not doing
the I'm trying to refer to like there's
like a thing that like different types
of gags okay
um yeah different so I'm like so what I
need to do is I didn't ask people a
question like are you in like bondage
and if you say yes then then I'll go ask
you all the bondage questions ah got it
right but then this seems simple but
then it just exploded because I'm like
how do I categorize these fetishes
there's like if you're into sploshing uh
which is what's that like uh you like
sitting in cakes you like getting in mud
but basically like kind of messy sensory
like is this a disgusting is it a
humiliation thing is it a sensory thing
like which category anyway so it took me
like two months of just agonizing over
each fetish because you don't want to
miss a fetish you don't want to like
have a really important thing that you
accidentally put in a discuss category
when it actually belongs in the
humiliation category you know well let
me think about that because like you're
still catching it you're just
miscategory categorizing it right
because if you're into splashing and
you're like this is clearly humiliation
sick so you say yes I'm into humiliation
stuff and then I don't ask you about
splashing then I'm missing a whole data
set of people
because of falsely categorized your
questions you're going to miss stuff
you're just picking what to what's less
and less important to miss well I'm
trying to get people into the right
questions set sure because like I can't
ask you all the questions I have to ask
you a couple overarching questions to
know what specific questions to ask you
and so I have to those overarching
questions have to be really really well
calibrated so that I can accurately feed
you into the right sub part of the
survey awesome so that was extremely
difficult if I'm when I'm dealing with I
think it was like 850 fetishes
um so I did a couple things to spot
check I like I did a couple questions
where I asked um like in the detailed in
the survey but like also the beginning
of the survey just to see like what
percentage people I was capturing
um but and then and then I scored the
survey so if you take it I had other
people answer preliminary surveys where
they gave me data about how taboo the
various fetishes were and then I used
that data so that when you fill out the
survey
um it's extremely comprehensive and you
get data about exactly how taboo your
interests are and you get a score at the
end and I gave you an equivalent kinky
character which I also had people write
a whole bunch of fictional characters
and some historic ones about like how
kinky they were so then I matched the
historic character Kiki character to
your score so that makes it like more
fun like gamifies it a little bit and
you could well you can brag about
and a lot of the characters really goofy
like like there's SpongeBob and like
Hitler's on there and you know South
Park characters what is what is uh what
king does Hitler have I think he's like
he's around Marilyn Monroe
which is like a slightly above average
oh sorry
I thought there was like a
two-dimensional space somehow so this is
like a literally from zero how kinky
yeah so there's a bottom who's uh the
most what's the character from Willy
Wonka
here
okay I think like maybe Captain America
was the least kinky or something or
Gandhi
meanwhile but that's another
conversation
boy
uh yeah so even viral and Tick Tock
basically because people were like what
I got this insane character and then Mr
the sample size exploded from 4 40 000
to 500 000.
wow so like all it took is that kind of
incentive what did you like uh at first
have to pay people for the server
foreign
people that took it I'm mostly younger
so usually early 20s
um predominantly female like 70 female
pretty like wraps out on Tick Tock
demographics pretty well yeah oh okay I
got it but that's interesting was young
people are probably better for this kind
of survey because there's probably a
culture that's a little bit more honest
about their sexuality uh yeah most
likely I think people are incentivized
to be honest when they're getting a true
identity response out of it
like sure if you're doing it for money
you don't care but like if you are
invested in the result you want to know
what the the truth of the answers are
then you actually
it's possible that you also don't want
to know that yeah this is true but on
average hopefully that doesn't I mean
there's these are really difficult like
what what is this some interesting
little quirks that
um people should know about about your
methodology that you had to kind of
solve to try to get to a really good
survey so one of you said is the
categorization to make it more efficient
is there some for the analysis part yeah
so the the graph that you're talking
about it's um it's a binary so it's like
if you and if somebody expressed even a
little bit of Interest then it goes into
the graph so it's like 80 of people
expressed even a little bit of Interest
so it's not representing degree of
interest it's not differentiating
between them at all so it's possible
that like some fetishes have exactly the
same amount of people like are at least
a little bit into them but one of them
is very extreme interest and the other
is like
fake and not very intense so that's not
reflected I also like probably didn't
represent the visual part right like
might not be intuitive but he chose a
log scale but it was kind of spreads
things out to makes it more and more
clear because the linear it was just so
clustered at the bottom you couldn't
really separate it out so there's
obviously a selection effects it's
possible that like the identity results
at the end impacted people's results a
little bit but the thing is like I'm
comparing it to what exists like what is
the alternative and right now the
research on this stuff is terrible so
it's like I'm not saying my research is
perfect um but it's like at least it's
something like it's something that's
pointing us maybe in a direction that we
might be able to do more research on and
you're making the data available yeah
yeah I'm doing it slowly because uh it
they're so I ask about so many questions
it's like not very anonymized so I'm
really seeing small sections of the data
at a time yeah
have you uh have you published in like
journals and stuff no I haven't you have
any any interest in that or is your your
approach I'm like I'm conflicted about
it like it sounds cool because then I
could really call her and publish on the
journal and then people who are yelling
about me who don't know anything about
statistics on Twitter like then I can go
like shove it in their face but then
you're also giving in to the silly
criticism like I don't like I want I
feel so passionate about extra science
like science that you can just just do
like I want to make science accessible
like anybody can just go look and learn
about the basics of like doing a survey
or figuring out how to interpret
information
um and doing a published Journal feels
like I'm I'm betraying my cause a little
bit
that's often behind the paywall yeah
it's uh it goes against the
I mean I think you not publishing a
journal is doing a big public service
thank you oh it's just coming from like
on this topic the elite the elitism I
see on the psychology side with the
journals and the Academia the positions
and the institutions you come from all
that that goes against
um I think that's more useful for math
and computer science and so on where
there's like
clear like but even then even then code
is code data is data yeah like uh
Prestige shouldn't matter at all
um maybe maybe for like
like biological experiments like
fireology or something like that
it's good to be from a major lab that
has a reputation for like going through
all the procedures like you know you can
trust but here like you're dealing with
a giant mess of humanity like it it's
beautiful to be transparent to be raw to
be exploring it together with everybody
else it's really beautiful I have people
like have a lot of incentive to doubt
the results like a lot of the research
I'm doing is to like assists and trans
people like like we don't have any data
about transsexuality like not very good
at least
um and I'm really curious I don't really
have an agenda about it I think like
being trans is cool if you want to be
trans do it and like I have some
skepticism about like gender Theory but
like it doesn't come down to impact like
the way I think trans people should be
treated which I think is like treat them
you know be [__] nice and human about
it I don't know but when I'm talking
about the the thing like my conclusions
are that like uh transsexuality is
really unique
um it's not like like sister or CIS
woman or man sexuality at all and me
this is super cool but like a lot of
people this is very politicized right
now like the data into like transsexual
preferences like it's so loaded which is
really sad because I am very accepting
of weird sexuality like if you're into a
weird thing I'm like good for you this
is super cool like let's figure out how
to make it so that you can explore the
thing you're into without any stigma but
because there's so much stigma that like
if you find that one demographic isn't a
weirder sex stuff than the other like
it's hard to present that in a way that
people don't weaponize so it's been it's
been really politically touchy subject
here yeah but you do it in a way that's
not this it's not feel like it has an
agenda right you're just exploring yeah
I feel pretty open to what I'm gonna
find like I often have no idea what the
date is going to tell me and I'm like I
pre-commit like okay I could say a b or
c and I'm like down to publish any of
those findings
uh so you've put together an Ask whole
cart deck yeah a lot of awesome
questions to ask at a party
or anywhere honestly
including on the podcast let me ask you
one from from from that deck is sex
really about power so what's the role of
power dynamics in sex
and then everything you understand like
in from the survey in terms of what
people are turned on by you've talked
about like the preferences that women
versus men have for like submissiveness
and dominance
and uh we've already talked about it a
little bit but like it's expressed more
strongly see I already forget the
results but I feel like women have more
preference to be submissive yeah this is
one of the things that got me into
researching fetches to begin with
because I think I came across some data
I did like a brief survey where about
roughly around 60 of women report being
submissive and 40 of men report being
dominant and this is really fascinating
to me like why is there this Gap like
why why do we not because I guess I have
some priors that maybe this is an
evolutionary thing like the submission
dominant like strong men and you know
like women would be like us hot hot man
you know the men are like ravaging and
stuff I'm like shouldn't this be a in
our jeans but but there's a gap
what's the Gap the Gap is the dominant
submissive Gap more women are submissive
and there are dominant men
oh yeah really yeah it's a pretty
significant Gap and this is held up like
it depends on what you're testing I've
tested a bunch of things this is part of
why I did this big survey nice but it
depends against again on like what kind
of dominance you're measuring but
overall it's a roughly 40 to 60 So when
you say there's not many dominant men
then the the meaning like they express
like a desire to be dominant in the
relationship yeah or like in sexually
sexually sexually in bed so like if I
ask questions like how much do you like
being dominant in bed like men are less
likely to answer strong yes to that
question but if I ask are you likely to
be submissive like women are very much
yes
really and that's expressive like that's
that that that represents truth
um my guess what's wrong with men so
this is I think there's some reflection
in like fet life so felt like this
website where people like sign up and
connect based on their fetishes and this
is like you can kind of see it picked up
in the Forum post about like how like
dominant men are you know are getting
laid so much and you know submissives
are always looking for a dominant like
there's it's an unequal Market holy [__]
yeah this is great news
I didn't know this that's interesting
yeah so what does it reflect about
modern society is that like uh is that
because you know there's these Trends
about like decreased masculinity or that
yeah so is that reflect is that that's
so much similar I'm trying not to hold
on to one Theory because I'm not sure
one is possible like decreasing
testosterone levels
um testosterone seems to be I have a
little bit of other research but I'm
still checking it out that seems to
indicate that uh higher testosterone
you're more likely to be dominant so if
we're seeing decreased testosterone
levels across Society where it should be
seeing a greater uh Gap
um this is so fascinating once again
this is like a super interesting way to
look at Humanity because it is such an
important part of humanity and so like
how many people are doing large-scale
research like this I feel like you're
like at the top of the world you're like
world class at the top of the world
doing research on this stuff yeah I
think I might have the biggest most
comprehensive fetish data set in the
world right now
that's epic thank you I'm really happy
about it I'm very proud yeah and it's
you know it's it's probably growing but
it's also enabling you to establish a
name to where you like a Prestige like a
reputation to where people can go to you
to like trust you more and more to do
longer surveys perhaps
like yeah maybe I think people it's the
date the data analysis afterwards is
very different from like the survey
design itself
so I'm still very amateur at the data
analysis yeah but you can always catch
up on that I guess the data analysis
does enable you to does teach you how to
ask better questions in order yes it
goes back and forth like as I'm looking
at the data it informs the way I want to
phrase questions the next time so women
are more at least in private able to
uh say that they would like to be
submissive and Men even in private are
not
disproportionately saying they're not
willing to be dominant
yeah so it's possible if this is caused
by decreasing testosterone levels and
this means that we're probably having
less satisfying sex overall like we're
becoming less and less sexually
compatible as time goes on to be fair
I'm not sure that it is connected to
testosterone levels like it's possible
that this is just like a genetic thing
like me the gay Uncle Theory like the
idea is like maybe gay people evolve to
like be sort of taking themselves out of
the gene pool to be but to be assistants
and like it's possible that like there's
certain percentage of men sort of like
quote unquote evolved to be submissive
to take themselves out of sexual
competition and to instead be like the
the monkeys revolving at the edge of the
pack oh it's a method of survival like
so you stay out of the competition yeah
and I'm like a little obsessed about
these kinds of Evo psych theories so I'm
not I'm just saying it because it's like
different ideas that are possible yeah
okay so yeah I'm not saying it's
definitely testosterone there's other
things it's also possible that it's
culture people are definitely gonna
bring that up based on my survey though
it doesn't seem to be any evidence of
that like I asked about uh like how much
pressure was put on you to be you know
agenty in your childhood like a lot of
questions around this kind of thing and
no correlation at all to dominance well
related to sexuality
I'm very uncomfortable right now but
nevertheless the plow forward
in a dominant fashion uh
uh the the blog post titled rape
Spectrum survey results
what are the key takeaways from that
survey so I did the survey when I had a
friend be like hey I had this confusing
sexual experience was it rape like
somebody kind of pressured her and she
eventually stopped saying her or
something I was like that's a great
question like I don't know how people
would consider this and so I put a whole
bunch of different gray uh scenarios uh
into a survey and then asked people to
rate how rapey they thought that
scenario was she actually like little
and like little narratives
yeah they get a rate like you know this
person is on a date with this person
they get drunk and the other person's
not drunk I try to keep gender neutral
uh
names for all of them and they you
reduce them into a more concise
description of the situation yeah like
in this visualization so you have this
rape Spectrum that's a result yeah where
on top are things that are less likely
to be considered raped by the people
that took the survey and the bottom more
likely
the the likeliest is a stranger forcibly
assaults someone who screams and fights
the entire time that gets a hundred
um what do we make of something that's
not zero it's like a 12 is what what is
that how are we supposed to interpret a
12 out of 100 that's extremely low okay
it's like not zero but it's just very
close to it having sex with an
enthusiastic sex worker yeah is it 12
that's the lowest one and there's a few
I'll just mention a few that are lower
like at that level have sex to make a
partner happy in a relationship lying
about wealth hobbies in order to get
laid
person with Down Syndrome eagerly has
sex within your typical not revealing
being transgender until after sex and so
on I think you mentioned that there's
some like either that not revealing
being transgender until after sex
there's some differences
amongst what men and women or something
like that I think that men found more
offensive than women I'm trying to I
wrote a little while ago
I mean uh this is nuanced and difficult
right is because uh I think in a lot of
public discourse the word rape is pretty
binary yeah it's like either one is or
is not rape and so you had a friend
whereas like this felt rapey
yeah she's like confused about how to
interpret it I think people look to the
terms to know how to feel about
something yeah like have you ever like
been through an experience you're like
that was weird and then you tell it to
somebody else and they're like oh my God
you were assaulted yeah and then it
totally recontextualizes the thing that
you've experienced and I think that this
is clunky with the word rape because
either you were raped or you're not you
either like have this entire context
like thrust upon you or you don't and
we're really noticed about it at all and
so I would really like to have some sort
of like oh that was like a 30 rape you
just endured
yeah and I mean there's probably other
dimensions about how traumatic it is how
difficult it is to recover from all that
kind of stuff
yeah I mean like people it's a dangerous
thing to assign a word to to an
experience like even or to a
relationship like saying a toxic
relationship
yeah that can completely destroy your
perception of that relationship
yeah absolutely I remember this was the
case with my childhood like I talked
about being very abusive but I've talked
about how like there's a good amount of
meaning there so that I didn't process
it as abusive at the time I remember
after I got out of that house in that
culture people would tell me oh your
child was really abusive and I was
really confused by that because it's a
total re-contextualization of that
narrative it's like the things that I
went through were not you know good and
virtuous and had meaning but rather
those were like the result of you know
parents who didn't like love you enough
or something uh and it even though the
the concrete things that happened to me
did not change like no facts shifted the
fact that like the the interpretation of
the fact shifted caused me quite a bit
of distress for a long time I was like
oh my God I'm you know I'm a traumatized
like abused person like I went through
an abusive childhood and it was really
hard for me it made it worse like it's
crazy the power that terms have
I think we didn't talk about this but
how did you how did you begin to
overcome
uh the the trauma of your childhood you
mentioned LSD so drugs are part of it
like what was the just the mental
journey of that
I was doing LCD quite a lot when I was
21. what's it like by the way I've never
done lsues what's it very difficult to
describe because it's like like it
changes sort of aspects about your
environment that are invisible to you
because they're so stable
is it like if you can compare it to like
psilocybin is it very different oh yeah
uh it's like similar I forgot that you
did shrooms yeah okay that you probably
know you know like the kind of shift
that you have from cyber dish rooms is
roughly similar it's like more clear I
think shrooms is more like embodied but
it LSD is much more intellectual for me
it strikes different people differently
I prefer shrooms a lot I'm sorry LSD
real estate a lot why is it not
popularly take like there seems to be a
negative connotation to LSD because like
it seems to potentially have like a
destructive effect like maybe dosage is
more difficult to get right or something
like that does this exactly
a long time ago I did a survey on
streams versus LSD so I asked people and
people had slightly stronger experiences
on LCD overall I remember but rated the
experience is about is equally good
um but I think people like streams
because it feels more natural
quote-unquote but I think if you like
fed somebody a shroom and like actually
had the LSD molecule in it they would
have a they would think it felt very
natural but that's besides the point I I
like I think people get kind of
incoherent on LSD in a way that feels
really alienating like I consider LCD my
LCD use very heavy to be one of the best
decisions I ever made in my life but I
definitely was incoherent for a lot of
it like talking about like we're all one
Consciousness everything is love man you
know and people are like is that
incoherent so I think it's not
incoherent but like if you go around
saying everything is love people are
like this guy's kind of blasted out of
his mind this podcast
is basically your lsdriver for a bunch
of episodes yeah I get this for sure oh
well well it's not just about love but
it's uh
it's about like talking in that way
about reality about the world yeah sure
it's like overfitting there's the
narratives that you make out the world
become really Vivid and so you pattern
match just really aggressively like
everything is connected and you come up
with these explanations for things and I
think I was very fortunate so I like
this theory about psychedelics where you
either like belief construct or you
don't so you take psychedelics and it
sort of like Burns away a lot of your
belief structure
um and sometimes you this happens and
then you're like I need to like invent
something to fill in the gaps so you're
like okay I I think that maybe uh time
is an illusion so I must now believe
that like we're actually in a Time Loop
or like time travel is possible so you
experience time differently and then you
come up with a different belief about
time uh whereas other people uh don't do
this belief construction at all like you
experience time differently and you sort
of let yourself not have a belief you're
not like okay and you're not developing
anybody's about time in its absence
you're just simply experiencing the
absence of the concept of time right uh
and so I I don't have a lot of data to
back this up in my my anecdotal
experience because I've trips at a lot
of people people either tend to believe
construct or they don't and people who
do not believe construct seem to get
more out of their LSD trips so if you
can let a belief go without building
anything in its absence it's much more
beneficial for you and I think I just
for some reason happen to have some
brain that's constructed where I don't
get a belief construction at all so oh
that's really interesting I believe
construction is negative
what
is it necessarily negative can you
elaborate a little bit I mean belief
Construction in a way that's like
uh
uh not like playing with frames but
rather committing to a different frame
so I sure I like I like being able to
play with ideas and be like let's look
at it this way or that way that's
awesome but if you're like okay you know
what I took LLC and now I absolutely
believe the cops are outside and you're
like dude no you're just like you you
can't shift out of that right like your
brain like needs to fill in the Gap
you're not allowed to have a gap so
you're not allowed to be flexible and
again I don't think this is like a
personal failing if any I think this is
like literally probably genetic or like
physical thing that's causing this but
do you think there's possible beliefs
that are like enlightening that you can
stick to like find a frame
that like
I guess if you don't believe
constructing you're escaping your
previous beliefs aren't you doing like
just some you're picking up a bigger
frame
yeah in some way you're taking your
beliefs as object as opposed to being
subject to them ah got it got it got it
got it and some of that I guess is
genetic and there's these categories of
people there's two categories that
experience LSD in different ways yeah
and you're one of those that are able to
just let go yeah I just think I had a
good reaction and I think a lot of maybe
the negative stereotype of LSD comes
from people who are belief constructing
or carry the belief constructing off of
the LSD trip so you take LSD and you're
like ah I'm leaving these insane things
and people from the outside see that and
they're like oh my God this person took
outstand became stupid yeah it's very
scary
um what's frame control because that's
been at the core of your trauma
at the core of your upbringing what's
frame control and also no sorry frame
control in general because that's part
of human interaction uh yeah Fame
control is like a way of manipulating
somebody else that is non-uh obvious so
there's a negative competition to that
usually uh yeah I mean I think maybe I
chose the term kind of poorly because I
think to some degree people are always a
little bit manipulating each other but I
think it's generally obvious like for
example if I disagree with you I want
you to believe what I believe yeah but
this is like an obvious thing that is
like visible between it's like an object
on the table it's like here's the box
where I want you to believe what the
disagreement box yes like right like
we're under a shared context where we
understand that like we're trying to
move each other yeah this is Chill to me
I think this is cool yeah we just all
the time and it's important but frame
control is the kind of thing where you
are trying carefully to obscure the
existence of that box yeah you're like
oh um the thing that I'm doing I'm like
using tactics to try to influence what
your reality is without us being both
aware that this is what I'm doing yeah
I've been assuming you're doing that the
whole time
no oh my God
I have to like figure out how to read
your facial expressions I'm still
learning there's none there's none you
don't have any I'm like uh I'm not even
like a Chad gbt I'm like gbt one with my
facial expressions like it's kind of off
like this doesn't seem to match emotions
but it's kind of intelligent seemingly
but definitely not conscious anyway so
like uh negative connotation
manipulating right not being honest
about the actual intentions of the uh
yeah of how you'd like to to control the
conversation I think there like might be
a naive version of interpreting this
where you're just like oh I'm trying to
like subtly get you to you know believe
like oh do you really think that's bad
though but this is not quite what I mean
I mean it's like a couple of concrete
things that are signs of frame control
um like one of them is pushing the
painful update button
um which is this thing where it's like
uh Hey if you uh learn this it's going
to be really painful the truth is
painful and if you're realizing this
thing about yourself it's gonna hurt and
this is a sign that you're heading in
the right direction so if you frame all
pain as a sign of of virtue then this
means that pain that's resulting as as
damage is something you're going to
ignore
so it's like this it's a common like
Cults right this is for your own good oh
uh you know you've faced the brave truth
about yourself that you're like not
quite as wise as I am
um when really your brain might be
trying to tell you protective things or
like another one is like finger trap
beliefs
um where you the belief is constructed
in such a way that doubting it lends
proof to the belief it's a very common
example is like Satan like the
Christians are like uh you know Satan is
going to try to make you doubt him the
existence of he's going to so doubt like
maybe he's not actually real and so if
you believe in Satan and then you're
like okay now I'm having doubts like
maybe he isn't real this is like oh this
is exactly what I was taught to expect
like I am doubting this belief because I
was told because like this is what Satan
does and it's taken as evidence for it
so like the attempt to move away from
the belief like re like rebounds on you
and like causes you to be more embedded
inside of the belief yeah so it's like
techniques like these like very subtle
things where like being inside of this
system sort of just self-reinforces the
system is what I consider to be frame
control and have you met people that are
really good at this kind of frame
control
yeah yeah definitely so like you you're
saying that your father was like that
yeah to be fair I'm not sure he was good
at it because I was a kid right I think
he's probably not very good at it
actually but when you're a child being
raised in a house where he works from
home and you're homeschooled uh it's
just kind of what's going to happen and
to be fair I do think that like strong
frame control is quite rare I don't
think most people are kind of doing
something like this but not nearly to
the degree that makes gives me the ick
yeah uh I've met maybe like five or six
people I think who I really don't like
because of those very subtle things that
they're doing I think also I'm starting
to kind of understand that there is
people who are
narcissists and sociopaths and
Psychopaths out there
and um
I'm not even sure if people like that
because I think they get good at frame
control
but I don't know if they're aware
they're doing it oh yeah which makes me
also nervous about myself like am I
doing frame control
yeah that's one of the big things it's
like like typically people you can't
think about incentive like you can't
think about oh is this person trying to
do it or not yeah it's like not the
quite not the way you have to look at
what are the effects programmatically
looking at the effects and then you also
have to do that with yourself
it's like very much like are you like
how much space are you making for the
other person's reality here like sure
are you are you giving power to the
other person because a big aspect of
frame controls you're carefully
rerouting the power to yourself
you're like I am the person who knows
I'm like you're having pain in your
beliefs because you're updating towards
the things that I believe like it's it's
just like a gravity well but if you're
if you're setting up the gravity well of
your interaction such that you're making
sure you're giving the other person
power over the shared reality you
inhabit I think it's a really good sign
that you're not doing problem control
so if you're making room for them yeah
okay unless we're talking about embed
then it then then it's all general
relativity from there and black holes
and stuff frame control bed frame
control bed frame control
um it took me a long time to get a bed
frame just I'm saying I know but you
wear a suit though
uh yeah uh so frame control on the
streets no frame in the sheets I don't
know I don't know what the funny thing
is to say though but there you have it
um so the LSD helped you escape the the
frame
of uh
can you like elaborate what what was the
frame that was
holding you back
from
like the frame constructed by your
childhood experience that was holding
you back as an intellectual as a thinker
as a free being in this world
well I was really [__] up like after I
left home and I it absorbed the external
narrative that I had been abused which
technically is true I'm not saying I
wasn't but like I absorbed this
narrative and I just remember having
like this burning coals in my chest at
all times like if I had to call out of
my factory work when Father's Day
happened because I was spending the
whole day sobbing because everybody's
talking about their fathers like I was
really messed up and it was because I
held this important thing this this idea
this Frame that I had been deeply
wronged like there was a correct way of
being and the world had violated that
something should not have happened like
my father should have left me and it was
like this this like like the shearing in
the nature of reality and that was
really agonizing to have and LSD really
messes with frames a lot it takes like
what you think is normal and really
screws with it and I didn't LLC like
several times before but there's one LSD
trip where I remember I went through my
entire childhood in my head because LC
like really makes your memories quite
Vivid like anything you visualize it's
like you're in it and so I just went and
very carefully deliberately went and
remembered every single memory that I
could have that was really painful for
me like the times that I lost friends
and all the things I valued and like
being broken because like my parents
especially my dad would refer to like
breaking me like explicitly we're gonna
break your will as all these times where
I was like they had successfully broken
I will over and over and it was horrible
I was just like sobbing tears streaming
down my face and then I like worked
through my whole child I got to the end
and I'm gonna tear up because every time
I talk about this it's just like the
sensation of like being free from that
for the first time is so incredible like
I remember
being outside of my house and
being able to like
go where I wanted and think what I
wanted and uh it was just
just so Blissful and I was soaked in
this gratitude on this trip just like
vibrating with complete joy for
everything like I was just looking
around like I could touch anything like
I could cry if I wanted to I wasn't
allowed to cry I thought I'd be
depressed I was trying to I got
depressed as a child and my parents were
like if you keep being depressed we're
gonna like force you to scrub the whole
house like just like the ability to have
a feeling
uh was so thrilling and I was so
grateful for this I was like I would do
anything to give this experience to
someone else or do anything
even if it was like putting them through
what I went through and then like with
that realization I was like oh it was
worth it the thing that I went through
was worth it for this I would do it
again to like be able to have this deep
gratitude for what I have now and then
that shifted the meaning frame because
before the meeting had been like
something had sheared something that
shouldn't have happened but now it's
like the exact right thing had happened
so it's almost a gift yeah I was like ah
I would not give up my childhood I would
do it again
and I believe that to this day for the
moment of discovering that freedom yeah
because like everything now my whole
life is in contrast to that and it's
awesome it's [__] great I'm really
thrilled about it
do you
is there part of you that hates your
father still
kind of like I don't want a relationship
with anymore after that there was some
forgiveness like I had this Burning I
would have nightmares about you know him
killing me or something and after that
it kind of stopped like the the fire in
my chest went away permanently after
that trip it was so fast it was like
before I was [__] up after that trip I
woke up the next day and I was clean wow
it was really severe uh and I definitely
don't want to be around him still like
he still like triggers the fear in my
body yeah but I don't have that hang up
anymore I'm like kind of I'm over it
like I've let go he's his own person
like ultimately he didn't get to decide
who he was in the same way that I didn't
get to decide who I was
so that's almost like a kind of at least
intellectual like forgiveness yeah for
him yeah
and that so that that trip just took you
through your whole
year Alone by the way when you're doing
the trip uh yeah I had roommates but the
trip was mostly alone I had somebody
else was like sitting in the room but
they weren't interacting with me so
you're sitting there experiencing all
this what's the timeline like how long
does it take to go through your whole
childhood I don't remember I mean time's
really messed up when you when you do
that I was listening to the soundtrack
of the fountain which is excellent yeah
I listened to that a lot when I did LSD
I know it's probably a couple hours
that's amazing I mean it's like
it would be all
it's just like a vivid experience of
your childhood yeah Moment by moment
trauma by trauma
it's good to experience it purely like
it just is what it is it just is grief
like it is loss
and you just are in it without having to
make it be anything
and it's so interesting that you can I
mean work through that so for a lot of
us
for a lot of human beings like childhood
is full of those kind of mini
traumas big or small and like working
through that it feels like what a lot of
life is about is trying to work through
that
and it feels like you have to kind of
relive it I guess that's what therapy is
about in part and be able to vocalize it
yeah I this is why I feel really
confused about the concept of trauma
like people use this word so much like
are you traumatized and I understand why
like this is why I feel confused about
it but part of me is like I wonder if by
using that term we're creating the
trauma in people they were using the
frame where the thing that happened to
you was not supposed to happen yeah yeah
maybe there needs to be a different
frame no I I agree with you thought I
just I've I've made friends with and
talked to this guy named uh Paul Conte
he wrote a book on on trauma he's an
incredible brilliant psychiatrist yeah
he's probably agrees with your kind of
oh that's cool I should read it yeah you
should
um maybe even talk he's a fascinating
human being I'd be um interested in the
um
a psychiatrist's perspective is really
interesting because it's a you did
you've been doing kind of an in-person
survey
because you've done done so many
patients like like he he's like just
talking to him
is fascinating because like if I
describe my experience or somebody
else's experience it I could see his
brain mapping it in interesting ways to
the tens of thousands of of like data
points he has in his head and it's like
of course that's what doctors do but
it's cool as the doctors basically the
doctor of the mind and um have like an
actual like like qualitative data and be
able to I mean that's where the poetic
stuff comes in ultimately as a
psychiatrist you're exploring the human
mind with a bit of a sort of romantic
element yeah it can't be really
systematic about it but I it does seem
like frame or not be able to just talk
through the experiences you had is
really powerful what about it is
appealing is it just like being able to
revisit it with new eyes no I don't know
exactly it just seems to work for people
I don't know if it's appealing it just
seems like
almost acknowledging to yourself that
things happen
um like I've said uh I think I've said
this before my brother who I love very
much I tried to set me on fire a few
times
and I I think I to me it's funny but I
wonder if I didn't talk about it like if
that would be traumatic maybe like
talking and laughing about it
because it was traumatic to me at the
time I see I was like I love you why are
you starting to have fire but it's what
kids do when they're like yeah
I was like I was whatever fights this is
what boys do like it's they're they're
crazy uh it makes total sense it's
probably funny and from his perspective
but yeah I wonder I want to bring that
to the surface of that that helps and
maybe LSD allows you to uh or different
drugs depending on the person allows you
to more vividly bring it to the surface
and then depending on your genetics be
able to find a better frame
that's fascinating human mind is
freaking fascinating
all right
what's romantic to you by the way
I'm not a big romance person what is uh
so you're not like so to you romantic is
like objective analysis
of the interactions between humans a
little bit like I do find kind of the
survey process that I did to be romantic
uh when I the guy that I asked out who
I'm still dating I was like hey you
squirted like how my survey you want to
like go eat food or something and his
response was like you want to try doing
three days in an Airbnb as our first
date I was like yeah and that was
romantic like the Bold leap into oh leap
into a really intense date I think you
mentioned it I think you mentioned
something also
um must have been a tweet or something
like that where if you
um if people want you to show up to a
thing
give like the time the location the
dress code
and
not no pressure for you to be there but
like show up if you want that was your
specification it's a great memory yeah
and then I think you said that you did
that for like some Castle in south south
of France it did yeah
that was in my early 20s people my
friends at home were taking prediction
markets on whether or not I was going to
get abducted and killed yeah what was
that like I mean what what um
you've traveled quite a bit like do you
take these giant risks what's what's
with that I think I used to more when I
was younger with the traveling I think
I'm a little traveled out now but
like my first one I moved out of Idaho
for the first time I moved to Australia
I just kind of yielded myself across the
globe
which verb did you just use yeah eat
it's like to yote yachted
eat so people do people is this like
slang is this like Urban Dictionary or
is this actual or yeah you have to like
feel another word like if you take a
thing and you just like curl it really
hard ah does it not feel like I eat
motion okay so you eat it so a great
this was aggressive so across the globe
with you didn't even stop in
I just hurled myself yeah absolutely
along the way I kept eating myself in
various places yeah and so at one point
I said Okay Cupid and somebody sent me a
long message being like you should come
I don't know I'm hosting a castle it's
some people I thought I met like I have
no idea who you are but I just bought a
plane ticket
I just went and it was life-changing I
ended up dating that guy for years and
he he changed my life quite a bit
because he he like was very agent in the
world and before that I wasn't agentee
agent T like uh
and can we expressing agent it sounds
like you were and don't you have to
express agency when you're eating
yourself across the world you have a
little bit like in the same way you
express agency when you eat LSD like the
only thing you actually do anything else
is like put the tab into your mouth and
then you just kind of Scream the whole
way after that yeah but I I there are a
lot of other things like I didn't feel
powerful enough to like go make events
happen or anything and it was this guy
uh he had a lot of agency in the sense
that he would just sort of create
realities through the people around him
be like okay we're gonna do this startup
or we're going to throw this incredible
event like let's just do it and it would
somehow happen and it was really cool to
see that
and so that one thing led to another and
it was one of the biggest impacts on my
life I think
yeah that's pretty bold as I would say
it's pretty romantic south of France
yeah yeah it was in a little castle is
in the winter so we were all closed up
by the fire
um
I'm jumping around here
Twitter poll have you ever hitchhiked
you posted this Twitter poll out of all
that was a big list of Twitter posts why
did you pick the hitchhiking one I don't
know because it's relevant to it oh
actually to traveling and I like that
one that's romantic too right I'm
actually terrified of hitchhiking but I
have done it a little bit also it's
terrifying it's not our magic too I'm
terrified of what oh so you you are
interacting with strangers
that's terrifying yeah
you still you go to south of France
yeah
but that was like a cohesive thing I
don't know like there's it made sense
there's like times where you're allowed
to be weird in times where you're not
and like if you're like
he had some fake before of society I'm
not sure okay
but some people are like hey we think
you're cool come to this party you're
like all right I'm allowed to come to
this party and be really weird but if
you're being picked up by a hitchhiker
they're going to want to make small talk
and you can't be weird or they're going
to kick you out
I kind of think
because Valentine's Day is coming up I'm
kind of thinking it's doing something
crazy I'm not sure
south of France sounds nice gotta like
you gotta go to like a crazy romantic
date with a woman you don't know at all
yeah I think I'm gonna like tweet
something and just like
how do I select randomly basically how
do you select totally randomly like not
not people from your audience no you
want no no no no from the audience but
in an interesting way random sufficient
So Random amongst good choices
couldn't you have people just like
submit a form with and then you just
randomize it and then select one and
then you just if it's terrible you just
go randomize it again like the first not
terrible option yeah sure somebody's
like drown yourself but I feel like then
it's no longer random you kind of want
to do random just do it and just do it
like across the world somewhere in some
random place just for like a single
event for like a dinner uh you got some
sort of itch in you
but yeah I mean yeah the the itch to
live
it's like like sometimes it's nice to
drop a little like chaos into a thing
right what's your chaos survey by the
way like you mentioned that earlier I
kind of saw it I don't know yeah that's
one of like the sort of artistic
attempts at a survey because you know
like at least from what I understand the
big five and the way that they used to
do IQ tests I've heard is that they do
factor analysis you know where they ask
a whole bunch of questions and then they
run calculations on the data to like
sort of group it by organic clusters so
like with the big five it's like people
who say oh I like to be at parties they
also tend to say yes to the questions
like I like being the center of
attention and so you notice that like
there's a cluster of ways people are
answering the question and then you can
sort of pull out an organic spectrum and
so I was like okay we've done that a
whole bunch with things like personality
or uh like romantic stuff like I did it
with the rape Spectrum survey but like
what happens if you apply that method to
a completely unselected group of
questions just like no random chaotic no
thing whatsoever like what happens is if
you ask all possible questions what
natural things evolve out of that
natural spectrums so I had other people
submit questions for a very large survey
and I took the first I think 1100
and barely filter them at all and then I
just had a whole bunch of people answer
them well
uh can you give like a hint to what it
looks like like what like how crazy the
question get
I mean a lot of them are standard but
somebody was like if there's above like
did something in 1512 to like turn the
world over would you would you like it I
don't know it's like it was really just
insane questions there's a couple of
those a lot of like would you [__] Ayla
once but
yeah once okay I got you yeah so it
really all it was like normal personal
habits it was you know romantic
preferences or political preferences
personality stuff like random opinions
about media okay that's interesting I'd
love to see those actually actual
questions but because your audience is
probably really a super interesting
Minds okay uh you mentioned body comp
you said you can answer that one easily
uh do you share your body count do you
know your body count do you know is
there a spreadsheet there's a
spreadsheet yes there's a Google Sheets
is it Excel sheets yeah okay have you
run like uh is there
you don't have to share the the the
contents but is there like data on each
so I track uh paid clients and free sex
separately and I attract different
things on either like with clients I
track like positions we used and who had
an orgasm and with personal people I
just track basically like age City
you know name
and I I I've had this I think 42 people
I think for free so it's I'm sharing
this because like I want people to
calibrate like it's not like huge it's
not like tiny one of the people I've
recently talked to uh Mel Destiny's
Stephen's uh wife is a huge fan of yours
uh she was actually really excited to
get to uh talk to you but she I think
she said her body count is more than 42
I think she said 60. something like this
and so
it's interesting because she was like
saying like she loves like looking at
your at your work talking to you
because you have similar perspectives on
the world and it's really refreshing
it's liberating
wow oh it's really sweet it's kind of
interesting yeah so what is there like
an optimal body comp like if you were to
map I wonder yeah what have you found
out about body count in doing have you
actually done surveys on body count like
on how many people have selected that
information on my last survey I just
haven't looked at it yet there's just so
many things to look at so I haven't yeah
but I think if I'm sleeping with a guy
and he's had sex with more than 120
people then I start to get a little bit
wary well 120 is opposed to 100 I don't
know I just like kind of skimmed through
the numbers in my head and picked one
that felt right just know yeah 120 ish I
think that's why I'm starting like uh so
you're flexible yeah
first
um but 200 is a hard line for sure well
it's you know we have to it depends the
factors because like there's a there's a
level of body count at which you start
to wonder if how much
like accidental misrepresentation a guy
is doing to you oh like if you're saying
200 that might be dishonest no like if
he's had sex with 200 girls uh this
means that he's had a lot of casual sex
um and not a lot of like long-term
relationships assuming that he's you
know hasn't been super poly yeah and
this usually means that there has to be
some sort of
um like indication that he cares about
the girl more than he actually does
like he oh because he's like leading you
on basically
um and so I'm not saying this is
necessarily the case I'm saying like at
a certain level of number I start to
become I start to wonder if this is
what's happening is there like from your
understanding of it is there a different
perception between men and women like if
you look at the high body count for a
woman versus a high body count for a man
like how Society views it oh yeah people
are way more judgmental of women uh I
haven't experienced this personally in
my circles because I'm in very
sex-friendly circles like I'm in orgy
circles where everybody like dates the
same women and they're like woo good job
uh but yeah you people are much more
like people always tell me online like
you're not we're going to be able to
find a husband because you have sex with
too many people okay it's very common
which I don't think I mean like men are
also perceived negatively if you have
high body count but I think I don't
think it's negatively in the same way
yeah do you think it's unethical to lie
about in your body count
yes so all lying is unethical yeah
I'm not a big fan of lying in general
yeah
yeah it's interesting bodycon's an
interesting one it's so silly to take
that to care about that but still we do
yeah jealousy is silly but still we get
jealous is that weird
I it's like the thing is like I don't
like viewing emotions as like irrational
even if they are it's like emotions are
always there for a reason and people
don't like high body counts for a reason
too they're just fine and valid yeah it
also is like
yeah I don't know what I make of just
the past of like time
you know like
like each human is a collection of
experiences
and you don't know most of those
experiences and all sudden you meet this
bag of experiences
and like what are you supposed to do
with both of your like training data
are you supposed to like like what
like I don't know if we like part of me
wants to not actually ever talk about it
to care at all like why does it matter
because only like the future is that
matters and yet the past also matters a
lot potentially but maybe not really
because you're you're you're somehow
like
constructed from that past but you're no
longer that past
like you're evaluating for something
different than those people what do you
mean like most the reason I'm just
talking out my ass but yes go ahead yeah
I'm just saying crazy [__] like as if
I'm on drugs like kind of sound I think
this is like kind of like lining up with
like this this caricature that I'm
building of you based on this
conversation so far great but uh like a
lot of people want to know about your
past because they want to know how
useful and compatible you are with them
like oh do you have a similar job you
know do you have similar culture like
what can I expect from you in the future
like it's very practically oriented
whereas like if the thing that you're
focused on is not like being able to
predict someone
like if the thing that you focus on is
the present moment then it doesn't
really matter anymore they're
they're the things that like their
training data but I also I also think
that the past is not that predictive of
the future is it not not if you believe
in the power of the interaction between
two humans second nature versus nurture
I guess also I don't believe in the in
the if in the ability of people to
accurately describe their own past this
is true because they have a very
specific lens through it that doesn't
necessarily like it's too biased
can also interpret based on the bias
like if somebody describes their own
past you can kind of pick up like hard
it's difficult like you would you could
if you're a therapist like if you're
really drilling like or whatever sorry
if you're really investigating and like
analyzing it but then it's like it's a
different kind of relationship right
isn't that hard though like if I'm with
the guide I'm considering dating him and
I asked like how did your past
relationships end and then if all of
them were like he's like oh she was
crazy and my other one that she went
crazy too I'm like okay like there's a
if you're talking about all of your exes
is insane like but that's an easy level
red flag but yeah I feel like the more
that also these possible they were crazy
he's attracted to crazy people so like
that yeah but but that I would say
that's like easier love easy level Mario
Kart video game versus like Elder ring
like like
I think most most people's past is like
complicated he's a pretty good bird no
you're right I do agree that like
there's a level of obscued obfuscation
wow that um is hard to see through but
this looks a little bit sometimes well I
tend to like with people I tend to in
general just human interaction I tend to
not talk about their past very much
because it allows you to focus on like I
feel like the past is kind of like
talking about the weather is a crutch
for me personally interesting like as
opposed to exploring the ideas in their
mind yeah I see is it like I I get
really annoyed when people quote
philosophers and they're trying to talk
about philosophy yeah is it like that
a little but that crutch is useful and
it's kind of sexy like it's kind of like
cool like because it's nice to quote
because like because a good quote allows
you to be cheesier than you otherwise
would be okay well if you're doing it to
be cheesy that's
it allows you to say a simple profound
thing that we're too afraid to say with
our own words so like the quoting
philosophers in that sense to see yeah
but it's still a crutch yes but I feel
like the past
is more like talking about your dreams
it just it's not
it's a crutch that doesn't care it
doesn't empathize with the other
person's experience of the conversation
or the explanations doesn't really
convey the uh they are not involved in
your past yeah so how do you feel about
this conversation or you're asking me
about my past and I talked about my past
a lot
well I'm okay asking about your past
because you've really carefully thought
about that aspect of it and we didn't
really talk about your past outside of
the things you've written about and I've
really thought about I see like there
there's like with most conversations
you'll start talking about past stuff
that's like the stuff that's actually
bothering you you still probably have
not written a blog post about right like
there's there's probably still stuff
like maybe it's it's more recent like
the last few months last couple years
like that's usually what we'll come up
with conversation and just
it's it's good it's good but it's not as
deep and I would say it's not as
intimate as talking about the actual
ideas in your mind I see and how you
interact with them so like the past is
interesting for the frame of like
sort of like the like I guess you're
right I guess we're talking a lot about
like narrative yeah in past yeah I like
the ideas in people's minds versus their
Recollections and memories and so on
yeah yeah
uh what do you think about porn
it's nice I like it okay you like it yes
uh what effect do you think it has on
society
uh like probably reduces rates of rape
because like really horny men get an
outlet that's not a real life woman Okay
so
what about like the um
I mean like I said I finished reading
Brave New World like the over
sexualization does it does it increase
like
the sexualization society that's not
into a degree it's not good or is this
is this good like the
are really does it alter
in a negative Direction our relationship
with sex
it's unclear like it might
I don't know how to evaluate this thing
right because this is like one of those
really charged things where like I kind
of don't trust anybody's arguments on it
because it's too charged
um but like there's another question
which is like is it a net positive or
net negative yeah like it's possible
that it might be like a net negative
four specifically our relationship to
sex but like a net positive overall in
general
I'm not sure but the thing my guess is
that in general it's better to let
people do the thing that feels good to
them and then the environment will
naturally modify to fit this thing and
then if we have more needs in response
to that then we're going to figure out a
way to take care of those needs so if
you're watching a bunch of porn and this
makes you like not want to go have sex
with women then we're gonna have to like
change the way that we like experience
IRL connection
um to compete with porn yeah which seems
like a natural evolution of like the
civilizational cycle like I'm
pro-natural Evolution and like instead
of trying to stop at things that people
wanted to actually figure out how to
integrate that and like find a more
healthy outlet but you have to then be
first honest with the effects that porn
has so like is it a negative thing is it
a positive thing on in real life
sex interaction
you know you're going to have that more
and more with
whether like
like porn and VR or maybe porn AI porn
yeah
like is that is that a bad thing like
what if porn with AI
or even like in physical space like sex
robots like what if that's more
pleasurable in a bunch of different
dimensions than with other humans then
we should figure out artificial wombs I
don't know
like how important is sex for society I
guess with between two humans yeah I
mean like we're having less sex than
making fewer babies and that seems like
probably not great
uh yeah right with the babies one
yeah but the babies there's probably
artificial ways to have babies that we
can figure out yeah but then how
important it sex to be human I guess sex
with other humans like we're gonna have
to figure that out in the century
yeah I don't know what it means to like
be human I'm I'm pretty on the pr the
transhumanist side of things I'm like
happy to stop being human
so you're okay if like the centuries the
last time will be something like these
biological bags of meat that we are
let's become something new and cooler
even though that thing would be way
cooler than you well I would like to I
mean I'm hoping that we get to be
immortal
ah it'll take you along for the ride
that's what I'm hoping I was like a
little clone my I'm I would like to do
cryonics you get Frozen when you die
are you afraid of death
I mean yes and no
I like came to terms with death would do
all of my LSD use but I still have like
press breaks when the red light happens
I think this is a this is a poll you've
asked or this might be
one of the questions in your cards but
uh how many years would you like to live
like if you had to pick oh that's
awesome that's a really hard maybe like
a million
a million but you have to like I think
the way this must have been a Twitter
poll I forget what it's Paul and also in
the deck of cards the [__] yeah
uh yeah like you have to pick that
number of years and you have to live
that many years and you can't live
anymore yeah you can't die sooner I
guess yeah a million years
I don't like that question so I know I
asked that question a lot of people but
I don't like answering it it's really
difficult what's the downside of a
million years
I mean maybe you want to die sooner than
that yeah like you know I guess I would
rather wait to see if AI kills us all in
the next 10 years and if it doesn't then
I'd like to maybe
make it a million years
yeah but can't torture you for like a
million years
what if you're the last human left yeah
that is i that's true the thought of
like civilization ending and then just
flooding his face alone is kind of
shitty no no being tortured just imagine
today you're torture tomorrow you're
tortured the third The Day After
Tomorrow sometimes it's not that scary I
don't know torture for a million years
yeah I just assume you'd get used to it
but like maybe if they reset your memory
so it was not a loop so you're always
experiencing torture for the first time
yeah hence torture torch is supposed to
be unpleasant I'm sure AI will be very
creative in figuring out how to torture
you
I think I would be I would go on the
safe side I was just like
like 150 years but really 150 though
that feels like right in like The
Uncanny Valley well you picked 120 for
body count so I'm picking 150.
of The Uncanny Valley
it's like probably everybody that you
grew up with is going to be dead it's
like just enough for like everybody you
know to die like one cycle
yeah and then start dating the Next
Generation no I don't know and then so
you get like sort of two lifetimes yeah
yeah
I mean it also really depends on if
other people get this feature
yeah I assume they don't
because you'll have like
fomo for sure for the people who picked
300 years oh yeah
or not or the other man regret another
human thing
but you're like what does transhumanism
mean to you in general so extension of
the of life extension of what it means
to be and a living conscious being
you're all for it whatever that means
yeah I didn't I never really thought
about the term transhumanism for a lot
like people say to transference I'm like
I don't really care but I slowly
realized that my attitude is in fact at
least the thing that I am conceiving of
as trans-humanist like I'm very happy to
do artificial wounds and you know upload
our brains to the great Collective and
whatever I don't have the thing that I'm
like oh what about like the true organic
humanness that makes us who we are like
whatever that soul of humanity I have no
attachment to it at all which I think is
what I'm thinking of as transhumanist
I'm like so you're like I I guess the
the window of what you consider to be
beautiful about life is not limited to
this particular definition yeah
let's explode like let's make our
Consciousness is huge
so AI could be a part of that wait so
you're mostly excited by AI well I mean
I'm like part of like the Doomer cult uh
I wish I say tongue-in-cheek it's not
actually a doom or cult but I'm part of
uh do you worship a god of some sort
would you sacrifice little small animals
that would make it look cooler than what
it is it's mostly just a bunch of nerds
who are very concerned about AI sure
yeah so you're concerned about the the
existential risks of chat GPT
of you know what chat gbt will
eventually evolve into being yeah yeah
it's super exciting and terrifying how
quickly it's accelerating yeah like
language models are freaking me out yeah
it's very unexpected that it's the same
exact I mean Chad GPT is just gpd3 3.5
it's the same same model relatively
small to what it could be
uh to what gpt4 will be in the other
competitors
and just like a few tricks made it much
better in terms of interaction with
humans and then we'll keep discovering
extra tricks the thing I'm really
excited about is how everyone kind of
knows how it works so you can kind of
create especially with computation
becoming cheaper and cheaper you'll
there'll be a lot of competitors yeah
it's a little scary yeah it's terrifying
I mean because like like the everything
is just like information ultimately like
the items that we have like weird
biological machines built out of the
tiny code like our DNA is just
information it's not hard if you have
access if you're like have a brilliant
brain that's like great processing
information you have complete control
over reality yes you have control over
the atom's ready all you need is like a
tiny little like Atomic printer uh and
like we have those those are cells right
and and I'm like this is like if the
limitation is information there is no
boundary between the technology and the
real world
like we are creating something that it
has a massive ability to affect the real
world I mean it's hard to know where if
how difficult is to close that Gap to
physical reality
like from the physics to the the
information you have like all organic
life is that Gap it's all around us
yeah but it's hard to know like how to
to go from digital to printing life
I don't know we can we look you know
crisper and stuff you can order you can
just like make sure you see uh right
there's technical difficulties and
there's cost like at scale like the
terrifying thing about AI is it can
accelerate overnight the capabilities
but the printing of stuff they actually
changing physical reality
is very costly it's very difficult to
exponentially accelerate the more
terrifying things AI becoming
exponentially intelligent and then
controlling humans which there's many of
us yeah and then that's how we achieve
skin we humans build stuff or start wars
or or so on like it starts manipulating
our minds gets in our mind becomes our
friends
and then starts uh I don't know yeah
thinking this is unlikely it's like it's
probably going to be as smart to us as
like we are to toddlers so we toddlers
thinking that like oh we can prevent the
AI from coming in the room like as an
adult it's like not hard to trick a
toddler
what about falling in love in the AI
system
do you think you'll have a sincere like
this is the freedom you have being
polyamorous you can kind of can fall in
with an AI no you and like it not really
have to dedicate your commit fully
like sorry you still commit but you have
others humans who you can kind of
diversify to because like it's kind of a
big thing
to like
to come to a party and your boyfriend is
an AI
and that's monogamous boyfriend is an AI
it's an issue right why would it be an
issue all right now you're already
getting uh offended at that possibility
which they're therefore I know it's
going to be a reality no I'm just joking
there's an issue I don't actually think
it's an issue I think it's uh
maybe at The Cutting Edge will be an
issue but like assume they have a body I
assume
yeah I think yeah but the body will be
really like crappy it'd be like R2D2 I
like I feel like we grow human bodies
already from like just a tiny little
cluster of cells especially and so all
they have to do is make that cluster and
grow it no no no no like don't that that
that the embryogenesis process like
that's really not well understood at all
that's really tough I think more much
more likely to have crappy humanoid
robotics like I don't think the body is
overrated in terms of like if if the AI
system is super intelligent
it can uh use charm
to make up for the crappy body yeah I
don't know I feel like if I were an AI
system and I were super intelligent I
probably would be able to solve the
problem of like growing organic matter
and then I would obviously just do that
you just build exactly the organic
machine that you want sure that's like
super intelligence I I think like with
language I'm worried about before it
that she's super intelligence
like true AGI it'll just be really good
at talking yeah that's true and like it
I I just don't think intelligence is a
very diff like basically a scientist and
a super intelligent scientist is a
different thing than just a good
conversation instead of party that can
undress you with their words would you
would you date an AI
I much way before then I could see
myself being friend friends with an AI
system yeah but like people are friends
with uh inanimate objects and
I have there's a robot behind you a lot
of them there's I like Lego robots
they're interesting it's on the Shelf oh
it was so cool cool yep I don't even
notice that
yep yeah Lego robots are they they we
anthropomorphize them even more because
there's something about the movement of
like
uh some like a thing that steps up steps
and looks up at you that there's a power
to that versus like a Roomba that's just
like
running into the walls yeah I think once
as soon as we get like some sort of
empathetic expression on robot face it's
over so we're gonna be like oh it's so
cute it's gonna be so easy to make it
cute too
if that's what you want or you want like
a dominant like clearly this is what
women want as a dominator yeah with
strong hands yeah
and and kind of dumb
uh or not I don't know that you can
customize customize it'd be interesting
to do a survey like how they would
customize it oh yeah like what would you
want in a perfect robot this is the
problem I I see with people the way they
talk about robots is they kind of want a
servant
I think what people don't realize what
they want in relationships they want
some like there's it has to be a push
and pull there there has to be some
resistance
like you you really don't want a servant
or even like the perfect manifestation
of what
what you think you want I think you want
imperfections around that like some
uncertainty I don't know I I question
how well we're able to perfectly
put on paper what we really want would
you really turn down like a perfect
woman though like assume like she walks
into the room and it's just shockingly
compatible and you like start dating her
and there's just no hiccups like you
fight perfectly like she really
understands you like would you be like
this is too perfect I'm upset because
we're not having enough imperfection
like you like actually imagine yourself
yeah I think so because
so because that's how you define perfect
because perfect for me would be like
easy and all that kind of stuff right
but then I'll be like this is too easy
because if I if I actually were to
introspect
what is the perfect relationship then
yes maybe because I probably want some
challenge probably want some chaos right
like you like does anyone really fully
want zero conflict
ever
like completely perfect conflict like
it's the thing that pressing a button
like do you really want in a
relationship anything you want you press
a button you get I don't think people
want that you might think you want that
yeah I guess it depends like there's a
kind of conflict that I think I would
never want which is something like
antagonistic conflict I wouldn't mind
disagreement
right you know but there's a level of
fighting I would be happy to have a
relationship for the rest of my life
that never has like a fight of a certain
shittiness
yeah but that's shittiness but like
resistance like um
I don't know what the example is
because I mean I partially agree with
you but I just and I every time I would
imagine like perfect Flawless nothing no
conflict you imagine somebody that
doesn't have like a
complexity of Personality right like I
feel like it's not even con it's
conflict that's Laden in misunder basic
misunderstanding between human beings
like misinterpretation different
perspectives that Clash different worlds
views different ideas all that kind of
stuff that conflict
yeah that sounds good yeah I like having
somebody like be like I don't think
that's right because I have this other
view that's cool and also like the
threat of leaving all right oh yeah
like that's a kind of conflict yeah
that's true like you have to be good
enough for the other person or maybe
you'll lose them yeah
and maybe a little jealousy like they
they're good at that but not too much
like
but like if I if you design all that in
then I don't know it sounds romantic it
sounds romantic okay all right I I do
want to really uh quickly ask you about
this about the the rationalist community
because I've
gotten to know a few of them a few times
he tweeted a guideline to rationalize
discourse basics of rationalist
discourse from less wrong what are these
folks What's the rationalist culture
what's the rationalize this course
uh yeah I love their astronauts because
they're interested like how do you have
conversations more effectively if you're
trying to figure out what's actually
true and which sounds kind of obvious
but in practice it's not usually
um I remember when I first started
having you know debating conversations I
was very antagonist I'm like oh I'm you
know a feminist or not a feminist and
then the rationalists were generally
like actually we don't know what we mean
by the term feminism let's like how do
you feel about that it was it was very
like uh kind and compassionate like even
if somebody says something that sounds
insane you're like okay well we're going
to respect your reasoning and like even
if we disagree let's actually figure out
why you think the way that you think
um and they're also really smart write a
whole bunch of great stuff about how to
think more clearly and with less bias
yeah I wonder what those conversations
because I've never really like talked to
those folks
so this guideline particular I think has
to refers to like shorthand
characteristics of rationalist discourse
um including expect good discourse to
require energy don't say
straightforwardly false Things Track for
yourself and distinguish for others your
inferences from your observations
estimate for yourself and make clear for
others your rough level of confidence in
your assertions make your claims clear
explicit and falsifiable or explicitly
acknowledge that you aren't doing so or
can't
so on and so forth so don't jump to
conclusions
don't weaponize equivocation don't abuse
categories don't engage it's very
aggressive guidelines don't engage I do
what I want I'll let my emotions guide
me God damn it they're Pro that as long
as you're explicit about it oh yeah yeah
so you can be like a crazy [__] as
long as you're explicit you can be like
epistemic status crazy [__]
who's here to destroy the the the the
quality of the conversation I think it's
like a common misconception about
rationalists is that they're kind of
like Spock like ah we used to press
emotion we're thinking logically hurt
eater but I found this to be really not
the case like I remember there's a less
strong thread where I was like really
emotional and I commented and at the
beginning I was like just warning I'm
just very emotional and then I just
vented my emotions and people respond
really well to that they're like cool
like you're just like genuinely
truthfully expressing your state this is
actual information about the world it is
important to hear and it's just they're
very interested in having things framed
correctly like you shouldn't be claiming
that your emotions are necessarily a
true version of the world and so as long
as you're just clear about what the
frame it is you're fine
how do you feel about this conversation
what could we have done better
I like the conversation I was a little
worried coming and I was like what if
he'll only asked a couple questions and
then we don't know what to talk about
yeah but it's been in quite a long time
and I I covered there's so many things I
didn't cover
I like the you have like a like I'm not
used to talking to somebody who feels
like some of the core way that they
approach the world is so different than
mine like usually the differences that
arrive like higher up the tree but like
there's something about like your root
system that I think is very different
from mine but also the way that you
engage with others is still flexible
like usually when I encounter somebody
with such a different root system
there's like it's like more aggressive
or something yeah but there's something
about the way that you're structured
that feels very gentle
all right
well I'm really happy we talked
something tells me we'll probably talk a
bunch more times I think you're a
fascinating human being I think I'm a
huge fan of your work uh maybe one more
question what's the meaning of life
to want things to to search
to be in
well I think your curiosity is like
somehow getting to that yeah to one
thing it's like curiosity like you don't
know I want to know the answer to like
be in the state of Yearning of wanting
yeah I wonder if you could do that if
you lived a million years just keep
yearning always that's the thing I'm
probably afraid of if I live just a
million years it's not the torture it's
like the yearning will fade you're
probably yearned to die then
I was just sitting there
wanting death intensely
that's kind of romantic a little bit it
has like a a bit of that spark
and constantly being denied wow
so most of your existence on Earth would
be spent deeply
intimate with death just thinking about
death
I think we're already doing that but if
I like hiding that from ourselves a
little bit anyway wanting
well this is an amazing conversation I
think you're an amazing researcher and
human being you're a great interviewer
I can see why you do this a lot I
appreciate it this is really fun Ella
thank you so much for talking with me
today thank you
thanks for listening to this
conversation with Ayla to support this
podcast please check out our sponsors in
the description and now let me leave you
with some words from Richard Feynman
physics is like sex sure it might give
you some practical results but that's
not why we do it
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time